GOOD MORNING
THANK YOU TO THE MEMBERS WHO ARE
HERE SO PROMPTLY AT NINE AM. AT
BEFORE WE BEGIN I'LL GO OVER A
FEW THINGS- WE CONTINUE TO TAKE
STEPS TO PRESERVE THE SAFETY OF
EVERYONE HERE AT THE CAPITOL.
AND TO ENSURE THE PUBLIC ACCESS
TO THE DISCUSSION TO ENSURE
MEMBERS OF THE MEDIA AND PUBLIC
HAVE ACCESS OUR PROCEEDINGS
TODAY THE HEARING WILL BE
STREAMED ON THE ASSEMBLY'S
WEBSITE. AND MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC CAN PROVIDE TESTIMONY IN
PERSON HERE IN ROOM FOR. FOUR
FOUR FOUR FOUR FOUR I DON'T EVEN
KNOW WHERE I AM. OR VIA THE
PHONE FOR ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC PRESENT HERE IN THE ROOM
WE ASK THAT YOU CONTINUE TO USE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING AS MARKED BY
THE SIGNS IN THE ROOM. AND
FOLLOW THE DIRECTIONS OF OUR
SERGEANTS AND POSTED GUIDANCE AT
ALL TIMES. IF ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY ON THE BILL OR THE
INFORMATIONAL ITEM FOLLOWING THE
BILL PRESENTATIONS. I'LL ASK YOU
TO THE MICROPHONE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. A COPY OF THE
AGENDA AND BACKGROUND MATERIALS
ARE AVAILABLE ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. TO PARTICIPATE VIA
PHONE- WE WILL BE PROVIDING
COMMENT VIA TELEPHONE USING A
MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE. THE
CALL IN NUMBER FOR THE HEARING
IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE
TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND
THE PEN IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE
FOUR FOUR FOUR. PLEASE CALL IN
WITH THE AUTHOR THE BILL YOU
WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT ON BEGIN
THE PRESENTATION OR WHEN THE
SECOND WITNESS ON THE
INFORMATIONAL ITEM BEGINS THEIR
PRESENTATION. THE OPERATOR ON
THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE PLACED
IN THE QUEUE. IF YOU ARE CALLING
IN PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE THAT INCLUDES
MUTING YOUR LIVE STREAM
BROADCAST. TO REDUCE SOUND
ISSUES. FINALLY I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE ASSEMBLY'S
BEEN EXPERIENCING A NUMBER OF
DISRUPTIONS IN COMMITTEE AND THE
FLOOR IN THE LAST FEW YEARS WE
WILL ENSURE THAT ALL VOICES ARE
HEARD THAT IS PART OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS HOWEVER.
CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS DISTURBS
OR OTHERWISE IMPEDE THE ORDERLY
CONDUCT OF THE HEARING IS
PROHIBITED. YOU FOR YOUR
COOPERATION YOUR PROJECT IS AND
TODAY. SO NOW I WANT TO CALL THE
HEARING OF THE WATER PARKS MY
LIFE COMMITTEE IN ORDER. YOU DO
NOT HAVE A QUORUM SO WE WILL ADD
BEGIN AS A SUBCOMMITTEE. AND I
SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS SO. PLEASE JOIN US. WE WILL HEAR AB SIXTEEN FORTY
FIVE I MISS BETWEEN US WHEN
YOU'RE READY. GOOD MORNING. GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AT
NUMBERS I AM HERE TO PRESENT AB
SIXTEEN FORTY FIVE I THIS IS A
DISTRICT BELL THAT WOULD EXTEND
THE CONCESSION AGREEMENT BETWEEN
THE CRYSTAL COVE STATE PARK AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION CHRIS TO CRYSTAL CAVE
STATE PARK IS ONE OF THE MOST
BELOVED BEACHES AND STATE PARKS
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IT'S
NESTLED IN THIS PARK IS THE
CRYSTAL COVE HISTORIC DISTRICT
WHICH CONTAINS FORTY FIVE
MINTAGE COTTAGES USED FOR LOW
COST OVERNIGHT STAYS AND
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS. I TWENTY
EIGHT OF THESE COTTAGE HAD HAVE
BEEN PAINSTAKINGLY RENOVATED AND%
SEVENTEEN ARE IN THE MIDST OF
BEEN RESTORED RIGHT NOW TO FIND
THESE RENOVATIONS CRYSTAL COVE
IS APPLYING FOR FEDERAL HISTORIC
TAX CREDITS BUT TO BE ELIGIBLE
THEY NEED TO EXTEND THE CURRENT
CONCESSION AGREEMENTS. I AB AT
SIXTEEN FORTY FIVE MAKES THIS
CHANGE TO ALLOW CRYSTAL COVE TO
DRIVE DOWN THESE FEDERAL DOLLARS
IN ORDER TO ENABLE THE STATE
PARK TO COMPLETE THE FINAL PHASE
OF THE HISTORIC RESTORATION
THANK YOU DIE I WOULD NOW LIKE
TO INTRODUCE MY PRIMARY WITNESS
THE PRESIDENT AT THE CRYSTAL
COVE BEACH COTTAGES DNG.
OPERATOR DO YOU HAVE DANTE ON
THE TELEPHONE LINE. THEY ARE
CONNECTED GREAT MISTER G. GO
AHEAD WHEN YOU'RE READY. WE
CANNOT HEAR YOU IF YOU'RE MUTED
. IF YOU WOULD CHECK IF THE
PHONE IS MUTED. WE ARE NOW WE
CAN ALL RIGHT GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE. THERE WE GO. GOOD
MORNING WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO
PROCEED YEAH YES PLEASE. OKAY
I'M HERE THIS MORNING TO-
CONFIRM WHAT YOU JUST HEARD THAT
THE REASON FOR THIS LEGISLATION
. IS REQUIRED IS THAT THE
FEDERAL TAX CREDITS AVAILABLE
WILL PROVIDE THE BALANCE OF THE
REQUIRED FUNDS. TO COMPLETE THE
RESTORATION PROJECT IN SEVENTEEN
HISTORIC COTTAGES AT CRYSTAL
COVE STATE PARK. UPON COMPLETION
H. COTTAGE WILL BE AVAILABLE FOR
RENT TO THE GENERAL PUBLIC. AT
RENT CONTROLLED RATES ARE WELL
BELOW COMMERCIAL RATES. ALL
OTHER EXPLANATION IS VERY WELL
DETAILED IN THE WRITTEN
MATERIALS ARE PRESENTED BY. OUR
CONGRESSWOMAN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER GEE DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT HERE
IN THE ROOM. NO DO YOU HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
AND L. THREE. TWEET TWEENER OKAY
WE'RE GOING TO SUPPORT FIRST.
ANY ADDITIONAL AT WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT ON THE TELEPHONE LINE.
OPERATOR IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE IN
EIGHTEEN T. SPECIALIST WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND WE WILL OPEN UP YOUR
MIND. AND CALL OUT YOUR MIND
NUMBER. IF YOU'RE ON A SPEAKER
PHONE PLEASE PICK UP YOUR
HANDSET AND PLEASE MAKE SURE
YOUR PHONE IS NOT MUTED BEFORE
PRESSING ANY BUTTON. WE DO HAVE
A LINE CHEWING UP ONE MOMENT
WHILE WE PROVIDE THEM MY NUMBER.
WE'LL GO TO LINE TWELVE GO AHEAD
PLEASE. GOOD MORNING ABIGAIL
MILE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PARKS FOUNDATION AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. YEAH. SEVEN
CARE WE HAVE NO FOR THE LINES
INTO THANK YOU SO WE HAVE NO
OPPOSITION ON FILE BUT WE HAVE A
WINNER IN THE ROOM SO WHY DON'T
YOU JOIN US AND- TAKE A POSITION
. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AND SERVE BLOCKS AND I'M
HERE REPRESENTING UNITE HERE
LOCAL ELEVEN IT IS THE LOCAL
UNION REPRESENTING THIRTY TWO
THOUSAND WORKERS IN HOTELS AND
RESTAURANTS IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND ARIZONA AND I
APOLOGIZE TO THE COMMITTEE- FOR
OUR LATE NOTICE WE ARE TWEENER-
SO WE ARE JUST RAISING SOME
CONCERNS- ESSENTIALLY THIS IS A
VERY VERY LONG LEASE- TO AN
EXTENSIVE THAT EXCLUSIVE
CONCESSIONAIRE THAT IS- AND
OPERATION THAT IS INCLUDING A
HOTEL A RESTAURANT A BAR- THAT
HAS HOUSEKEEPING SERVICES
CATERING SERVICES- WITH ROOMS
THAT ARE. LOVELY AND BOOKED SIX
MONTHS IN ADVANCE SOME GOING FOR
TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY NINE
DOLLARS SO OUR CONCERN IS
ESSENTIALLY THAT DISAGREEMENTS
AND THIS LEGISLATION DOES NOT
INCLUDE ANY- REQUIREMENT OR
PROTECTIONS FOR TAXPAYERS OR FOR
WORKERS THAT HAVE BEEN INCLUDED
BY OTHER JURISDICTIONS SUCH AS
LOS ANGELES OR LONG BEACH THOSE
JURISDICTIONS. FOR THEIR
HOSPITALITY CONTRACTS HAVE
REQUIREMENTS SUCH AS RESPONSIBLE
CONTRACTOR THEY HAVE LIVING WAGE
REQUIREMENTS THEY HAVE- WORKER
RETENTION AND SO THIS IS A
WONDERFUL PROJECT THAT HAS THE
GOAL OF PROVIDING LOW COST
ACCOMMODATION SO ALL
CALIFORNIANS CAN HAVE ACCESS TO
THE COAST WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WORKERS HAVE THE SAME
ACCESS AND ARE ABLE TO STAY AT
THESE COTTAGES AND LIVE IN THE
AREA WHERE THEY WORK- SO WE VERY
MUCH LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR IS THIS BILL
MOVES FORWARD- AND HOPEFULLY
WILL I DO BELIEVE WILL BE
MEETING TODAY AS WELL- BUT JUST
WANTED TO RAISE THOSE FOR THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU YEAH ANY
OTHER OPPOSITION. PARTY GUEST
WINNERS HERE IN THE ROOM. SEEING
NINE OPERATED WE HAVE ANY. ON
THE TELEPHONE LINE. IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. THAT IS WHERE WE HAVE NO ONE
TO THE THANK YOU ANY MEMBERS
HAVE QUESTIONS. YES KAMALA.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- THE FOR
THE AUTHORED THE QUESTION BEGS
AN ANSWER THERE WHY THE TERM A
FIFTY FIVE YEARS WHEN THE
FEDERAL- ACTION UP FOR THE-
CONCESSIONNAIRE NORMALLY WOULD
BE A LITTLE LESS EFFECTIVE THE
AROUND HIRTY NINE YEARS SO WHY
THE EXTRA. LENGTH OF TIME SO I'M
UNDER EXISTING EXISTING LAWS
STATE PARKS TODAY HAS THE
AUTHORITY WITH AT THIS PROJECTS
OR IN ANY OTHER PARK TO ENTER
INTO A CONTRACT OF A FIFTY YEAR
PERIOD. I WITH A CONCESSIONAIRE
THAT'S MAKING CAPITAL
INVESTMENTS I'M IN THAT THE
LOGIC FOR THAT IS TO ENABLE
CONCESSIONAIRE TO RECOUP THOSE
THOSE INVESTMENTS SO THAT IS
EXISTING THIS FIVE WOULD EXTEND
EXISTING LAWN BY FIVE YEARS. IN
ORDER FOR THEM TO BE ELIGIBLE
FOR AT THE MAXIMUM QUALIFYING
FEDERAL TAX CREDIT SO OUR GOAL
HERE REALLY IS TO ENSURE THAT
WE'RE NOT LEAVING ANY FEDERAL
DOLLARS ON THE TABLE- TO MOVE
THIS PROJECT FORWARD THANK YOU
FOR THAT RESPONSE. JUST GOOD
CLARIFICATION BECAUSE OF A
PERSONALLY BEEN TO CRYSTAL COVE
IT IS A BEAUTIFUL SPOT. BUT
YOU'RE ASKING FOR FIFTY FIVE
YEARS TO CURRENTLY HAVE THIRTY
SECURE SO WE'RE ONLY EXTENDED IT
ACTUALLY NINETEEN YEARS TO DO
THE MATH TO GET INTO THE FIFTY
FIVE YEAR THRESHOLD. THANK YOU
YES. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FOR THAT CLARIFICATION CORRECT
THANK. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS AM I
HAVE ONE QUESTION FOR AUTHOR SO.
I'M AS POINTED OUT BY OUR
COLLEAGUES THIS MERELY EXTENDS
THE AMOUNT OF TIME THAT THEY
CAN. EXTEND THE CONCESSION
CONTRACT BUT I ASSUME IT WILL GO
THROUGH I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
PROCESS IS TO EXTEND A CONTRACT
IN CALIFORNIA. BUT I ASSUME IT
WILL GO THROUGH ALL OF THE
PUBLIC PROCESS WITH WHICH-
INDIVIDUALS COULD ENGAGE AS IT
USUALLY WITH THIS DOESN'T CHANGE
THAT. CORRECT YES SO AS I SAID
WITH EXISTING LAWS STATE PARK'S
DOES HAVE EXISTING AUTHORITY TO.
ENTER INTO A CONTRACT OF THE
PERIOD OF UP TO FIFTY YEARS. I
IN ORDER TO FOR A CONCESSIONAIRE
THAT'S MAKING A CAPITAL
INVESTMENT IMPROVEMENT. IN ORDER
FOR THEM TO RECOUP THOSE COSTS
AND CERTAINLY WILL. IT HERE TOO
AT THE REQUIREMENTS- THAT ARE
ARE ALREADY ESTABLISHED IN STATE
LAW. AS PART OF THIS AND- YEAH I
WOULD NOTE AS SAID THAT THEY-
THAT I GUESS TWEENER COMMENT
TIME NOTED. THEIR CONCERNS WERE
BY RAISED BY YESTERDAY. AND AB
REALLY HAPPY TO CONTINUE THAT
CONVERSATION AND WORK WITH OUR
OUR TWITTER YOU KNOW POTENTIAL
OPPOSITION. I TO ENSURE THAT
SAID THAT THIS IS A PROJECT
THAT'S GOING TO HAVE. TREMENDOUS
BENEFITS FOR THE SURROUNDING
COMMUNITY AND REALLY FOR ALL OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU I
THINK IT'S A IT SEEMS LIKE A
SMALL CHANGE TO MAKE TO ADD
INCREDIBLE BENEFIT. A CO AND
LIKE THE- ACTUALLY. OUT MAKE
SURE THAT I CALIFORNIA HAVE FOR
LACK. HOPEFULLY TO- THE COAST ON
ONGOING OPPORTUNITIES I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
AND- WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. I
WOULD JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU ADAM
CHARTER WE ARE STILL OPERATING
THE SUBCOMMITTEE SO WE WILL TAKE
A VOTE WHEN WE GET TO ACQUIRE.
THANK YOU MISTER TURNER THANK
YOU SO MUCH. YEAH ONE. SEVEN
COMPANIES EIGHTEEN POINT ONE
YEAH. FOR AND I'LL TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO POINT OUT TO HER
MEMBERS HERE THAT FOUR SIX THREE
HAS BEEN SB FORCING THREE HAS
BEEN PULLED BY THE ALL SO WE
WON'T BE HEARING TODAY. MISTER
COOL WE WILL NOW HEAR AB AB
TWENTY ONE TWENTY EIGHTH BY MR
COOLEY. JOINT BELIEVE. OKAY AND
WE HAVE A QUORUM SEMICIRCULAR A
SEAT BUT AND WE'RE GONNA CALL
THE ROLL BEFORE WE BEGIN. OUR
QUE HAN. HERE DOLLY SENATE BILL
HERE FRIEDMAN R. C. KALRA LEVINE
MURATSUCHI NO ONE. RUBIO SALAS
SMITH THE APPROVED WHAT. WARD
OUR AND HUNDRED ANIMATION ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IF ANYONE SO GO
WITH THE SECOND. CALDERON
CONTENT CALENDAR. THERE CAN I
BARRICADE AYE. DOLLY THE I
BENNETT BENNETT I BIGELOW
BIGELOW I FRIEDMAN GARCIA GARCIA
I'D KALRA LEVINE MURATSUCHI WHEN
I RUBIO RUBIO AYE SALAS. SMITH
SMITH I THE VALLAPUDUA WARD.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
MISTER COOLEY WE'RE READY WHEN
YOU ARE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS
AN HONOR TO BE HERE I'M HERE TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY
EIGHT. THIS RELATES TO.
IMPROVING ENCOURAGING FRANKLY
ACCESS INTO OUR STATE PARKS ON
EACH ADMISSIONS DAY IN
CALIFORNIA SEPTEMBER NIGHT. THIS
ACTUALLY COMES OUT OF MY
PERSONAL LIFE EXPERIENCE IN
SENSE OF B. WHILE I WAS ON THE
CITY COUNCIL RANCHO CORDOVA
EVERY COUPLE OF YEARS. I WOULD
WORK WITH ONE OF MY MIDDLE
SCHOOLS AND WE WILL TAKE A GROUP
OF MIDDLE SCHOOLERS. DOWN TO
CAMP IN NEW BRIGHTON STATE
BEACH. AND I WOULD JUST FOR THE
WRANGLER I RUN THE CAMPSITE. SO
YOU CAN IMAGINE AT FOUR DAYS
WITH A GROUP OF A HUNDRED. I
WOULD RUN THE FOOD OPERATION
FEED EVERYBODY WHILE THE TEACHER
TO THE MATH SCIENCE CAMP. AND
BECAME VERY EVIDENT TO ME AS A
COUNSELOR RANCHO CORDOVA. LOOK
AT THAT FOR NIGHT THAT ARRIVED.
WE HAD LOTS OF KIDS. FROM RANCHO
CORDOVA CALIFORNIA DOWN THE
OCEAN WHO HAD NEVER CAMPED. AND
IN MANY CASES NEVER EVEN SEEN
THE OCEAN BEFORE. SO JUST REALLY
AN EYE OPENER FOR ME TO TAKE
KIDS R. RANCHO CORDOVA OVER THE
COAST AND THE COURTESY THE
WONDER AND AMAZEMENT OF THAT
EXPERIENCE. SO THIS BILL WOULD
PREVENT A 50% DISCOUNT UPON
ENTRY TO ANY CALIFORNIA STATE
PARK ON SEPTEMBER NINTH EVERY
YEAR WHICH IS OUR MISSION STATE.
TO JUST TRYING TO ENCOURAGE
PEOPLE TO GET OUT EXPLORE ALL OF
OUR PARKS WITH THE BOLSA CHICA.
OF PROVIDENCE MOUNTAIN. GRINDED
ROCKS THERE IN AMADOR COUNTY
CALAVERAS BIG TREES TO JUST GET
PEOPLE OUT AND ENGAGE WITH TE
WORLD AROUND US- OBVIOUSLY OUR
STATE PARK SYSTEM WHICH IS
HIGHLY DIVERSE HAS MORE THAN TWO
HUNDRED UNITS. CONTAIN SOME OF
THE FINEST MOST DIVERSE NATURAL
CULTURAL. AND RECREATION
RESOURCE IN THE NATION WHICH
JUST AFFECTS THE DIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AND ALL THE DIFFERENT
ELEMENTS THAT MAKE UP OUR
LANDSCAPE- AND- BUT NOT
EVERYONE. HAS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
GET OUT THEY MAY NOT. IT
AFFORDABILITY COULD BE AN ISSUE
BUT IT'S ALSO FRANKLY JUST GIVE
A MOTIVATION. PARKS ARE HERE
EVERY DAY SO YEAH WE'LL GO VISIT
BUT WHEN. ON SO ANYWAY I WILL IT
IS IMPORTANT TO CONNECT WITH
THIS HERITAGE I DEFINITELY KNOW
THAT OF I JUST KNOW WHAT A-
SOURCE TO WONDER IT WAS TO GET
KIDS OUT IN THE OUT OF DOORS.
AND DOWN THE BEACH AND WATCHING
THE WAVES COME IN AND- SOLVING
PROBLEMS TOGETHER WHICH IS WHAT
. IT'S SPECIFICALLY ABOUT
SCIENCE CAMP AIMS TO DO BUT
ACTUALLY ANY FAMILY GOING
CAMPING HERE YOU'RE JUST DEALING
WITH THE NEWNESS OF THAT
EXPERIENCE- I DO BELIEVE I'M
SUPPORT TODAY- ON THE PHONE LINE
BY RACHEL NORTON. WHO'S EXECUTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION- AND- SO MAYBE I'LL
DEFER TO SEE IF SHE'S WITH US
YEAH OPERATOR DO HAVE MISS
NORTON ON THE PHONE.
DISCONNECTED THIS MORNING YOU
MAY BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANKS RIGHT GOOD MORNING CAN
YOU ALL HEAR ME WE CAN THANK YOU
GO AHEAD. ALL RIGHT GREAT THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOLEY AN
HONORABLE CHAIR BAUER K. HAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I AM
INDEED RACHEL NORTON AND I NEED
A SECOND DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA
STATE PARKS FOUNDATION.
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION IS AN INDEPENDENT
SEVENTY THOUSAND MEMBER
SUPPORTED NONPROFIT THAT
MOBILIZES A DIVERSE NETWORK OF
CALIFORNIANS TO PROTECT AND
PRESERVE OUR CALIFORNIA STATE
PARK SYSTEM FOR THE BENEFIT OF
ALL. AND WE'RE REALLY THANKFUL
TO BE HERE EVEN VIRTUALLY
BECAUSE SUPPORT AB TWENTY ONE
TWENTY EIGHT BECAUSE CALIFORNIA
STATE PARKS OFFER ACCESS TO
WORLD CLASS NATURE WITH
OPPORTUNITIES FOR RECREATION
THAT ME ALL CALIFORNIANS NEED.
HOWEVER AS MANY OF YOU ARE AWARE
MORE THAN A THIRD OF
CALIFORNIANS LIVE IN POVERTY AND
IN A RECENT STUDY UCLA FOUND
THAT 59% OF THE STATE'S MOST
ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED
HOUSEHOLDS LIVE WITH A HALF MILE
WALK. A TWO MILE BIKE RIDE OR A
TWENTY THREE MILE DRIVE THE
STATE PARK. BUT THE FULL PRICE
OF ENTRY MAY POSE A BARRIER THAT
KEEPS CALIFORNIANS FROM
EXPERIENCING THE STATE'S CROWN
JEWEL ARE MAGNIFICENT STATE PARK
SYSTEM. CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION SUPPORTS THIS
LEGISLATION BECAUSE IT REDUCES
BARRIERS TO PARTS OF THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS TO THE
POSITIVE IMPACT THAT PARKS BOB.
ON OUR HEALTH OUR HAPPINESS AND
OUR QUALITY OF LIFE. I WANT TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOLEY FOR
HIS LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE AND
HIS ACKNOWLEDGEMENT AND
LEGISLATION THAT STATE PARKS
CANS THAT LIMITATION. ON
DISCOUNT DAYS TO MANAGE
OVERCROWDING. DAMAGE TEN NATURAL
AND CULTURAL RESOURCES AND TO
SUPPORT PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY. SO AS WE MOVE THROUGH
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING TO FIND THE
SOURCE OF RESOURCES TO OFFSET
ANY LOSS OF REVENUE. FROM THE
DISCOUNT DAYS OF THAT STATE
PARKS CAN REMAIN WHOLE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND
ATTENTION TODAY AND WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU MISS NORTON DO WE HAVE
ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT. HERE
ROOM. C. NON OPERATOR TO HAVE
ANY SOME ON THE TELEPHONE LINES
. TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS
ISSUE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE'LL GO TO LINE
TWELVE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
AFTER A MILE AND A HALF THE
POTENTIAL REGIONAL OPEN SPACE
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. BETTINGER WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE THAT YOU. THANK YOU TO
HAVE ANY OPPOSITION TO THAT
SWEET NOT ON FILE TO ANY
OPPOSITION HERE IN THE ROOM.
SEEING NON OPERATOR WE SEE IF
THERE'S ANY OPPOSITION ON THE
TELEPHONE LINE. TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. THERE IS ONE IN Q.
MEDICARE PLEASE PROCEED THANK
YELL AT ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE THIS BILL. MR HERE.
THANK YOU MISTER MISTER COOLEY
FOR THIS BUT I JUST HAVE A
QUESTION OF WHY NOT COMPLETELY
ELIMINATE THE FEE FOR THIS ONE
DAY YEAH. HOW DID WE LAND ON THE
50% I THINK THERE'S APPREHENSION
ABOUT. BUDGET ISSUES- YOU KNOW I
THINK IT'S- YEAH I THINK A HALF
OFF IS A GOOD. PLACE TO BE
ACTUALLY MADE PEOPLE BUDGET A
LITTLE BIT I DON'T THINK IT'S-
AN OVERWHELMING BURDEN. ON LONG
TERM I LIKE THAT THERE'S PLENTY
OF STATES THAT ACTUALLY DON'T
CHARGE FOR THEIR STATE PARKS-
BUT I THINK AS A TO INTRODUCED
THE IDEA. TO WORK OUT THE
MECHANICS OF HOW HEAVILY
IMPACTED PARKS YOU MIGHT
RESTRICT SOME RULES I THINK THIS
GIVES US A GETS US IN THE SPACE
OF SUCH AND I THINK. I THINK THE
LOGIC IS COMPELLING. I BUT- I'M
NOT LOOKING TO. RUN INTO BUDGET
TROUBLES ON IDEA THAT I THINK IS
SO IMPORTANT. I MEAN I SIT HERE
THINK OF ALL THE CAMPING I'VE
DONE OF COURSE AS A SCOUT
MASTER. I'VE BEEN DOING CAMPING
FOREVER I HAVE ACTUALLY A- WELL
A WHOLE HA IT TRUNKS OF
EQUIPMENT IN MY GARAGE AT HOME
AND I CAN FEED A HUNDRED PEOPLE
FOR FOUR DAYS PORTABLE STEAM
TABLES THE WHOLE NINE YARDS AND
YOU JUST THINK ABOUT THE
EXPERIENCE MY FUNNIEST CAMPING
EXPERIENCE I REMEMBER CAMPAIGN.
ONCE IN A- IN A KIND OF ISOLATED
AREA WITH A BUNCH OF. JUNIOR
HIGH SCHOOL KIDS. AND ABOUT ONE
AM. THE STILL THE NIGHT WAS
BROKEN BY THIS TERRIBLE
TERRIFIED SCREAMING. AND COULD
NOT IMAGINE WHAT WAS GOING ON SO
IT HELPED ME IN THE OTHER ADULTS
WE PILE OUT WE GO FIND A SOURCE
OF SCREAMING AND IT TURNS OUT
THAT A BUNCH OF MIDDLE SCHOOLERS
RED TENT. AND LITTLE WIGGLE
WORMS IN THEIR SPRAWLING AS THEY
WERE SLEEPING IN SLEEPING BAGS
ONE SLID INTO ANOTHER. AND THE
OTHER WAS CONVINCED THAT RACCOON
WAS ATTACKING JUST THAT THE- THE
HAIR GOT IN THERE HE SAID THERE
SORT OF LIKE SO AFRAID. SO WE
HAD TO SETTLE THINGS DOWN NO
RACCOONS IN THE TENTS. YEAH BUT
A JUSTICE IT'S A IT'S A YOU
CAN'T IMAGINE HOW AMAZING THIS
SORT OF EXPERIENCES- ANOTHER WE
ALWAYS SAID WE JUST TAKE A
MOONLIT HIKE DOWN OFF THE BLUFFS
OF- NEW BRIGHTON STATE BEACH
DOWN THE BEACH WHAT THE TEACHERS
ATTENDED SEN. YOU KNOW MOONLIGHT
ON THE OCEAN THE ROLE THE WAVES
EVERYTHING IT'S JUST AMAZING SO
I JUST THINK IT'S TO GET OUR
KIDS OUT TO SEE THE BEAUTY
THERE- SO I SORT OF FAVOR THAT
IS A LONG TERM POLICY BUT TO
GOVERN IS TO CHOOSE REDUCE FOR
TO MAKE A CHOICE. I'M A BIG
BELIEVER IN A IN AN OLD CHINESE
PROVERB FOR HOW CHANGE HAPPENS
WHICH IS TAKE FROM GEOMETRY
WHICH WAS MY BATH MAT MATH POINT
LINE PLANE. IN IN TO HELP JUST
TALKING SPACE ADD A SECOND POINT
NOW WE HAVE A LINE. THAT A THIRD
POINT NOW WE HAVE A PLACE TO
FIND. AND I THINK THIS IS A
POINT THIS IS A POINT OF
BEGINNING. A REPRESENTS THIS
IDEA- IT CAN BE TAILORED TO
THOSE PARKS ARE HEAVILY
IMPACTED. BUT I THINK IT'S WE
ARE SO INVESTED ALL THESE PARKS
. WHY STUNT THE INVESTMENT. BILL
WHY NOT ENCOURAGE FAMILIES AND
KIDS TO DISCOVER THAT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH URGENT I WILL. UP
REGULAR REGULAR HAS A QUESTION.
I THINK HE STILL HAS NOT BEEN
DISCUSSED PLEASE. I I'M GOING TO
VOTE FOR YOUR BILL TODAY AND
SECOND TWO IS COMING FOR ME I'M
GONNA. LOOK FOR YOUR ON A- I WE
START WITH POINT I WAS AMENITIES
CYPRESS THE JOB THAT REFERENCE
ANTI TEND WE START WITH THE
POINT AND BUILD FROM. THERE AND
THAT'S WHERE I'VE I'VE HAD TO DO
THAT MANY ATTENTION COMPROMISED
AND WE ALL RUN INTO THIS BUT
YOUR WEALTH ALONG THE WAY SO I
APPRECIATE IT BUT AS PEOPLE ARE
THINKING ABOUT THIS I THINK.
YOUR APPROACH TO ENCOURAGE OUR
YOUTH TO BE IN THAT THE SPACE IS
GREAT AND HONORABLE AND I
SUPPORT THAT BUT OUR MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE
THE HARDEST AXIS EVEN THAT HALF
PRICE OFF THAT'S ONE DAY- MAKES
IT HARD AND SAYS WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT EQUITY. AND WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT UNPRECEDENTED BUDGETS- FOR
THOSE FOLKS WHO WHO ARE IN
CHARGE OF THE SPUR STRINGS HAVE
HOPE THAT THEY LOOK AT YOUR OF
YOUR PRAGMATIC WAYS TO MAYBE.
SUPPLEMENTED THAT WE GET TO THAT
FREE ON A ONE DAY ONE DAY OUT OF
THE YEAR- AND SO FOR SOME PART.
I'M ALSO AWARE OF HOW TIGHT
BUDGETS ARE FOR OUR PARKS OUT
THERE BUT I HOPE AT THE STATE WE
CAN GET THERE NOT JUST FOR ONE
DAY BUT JUST IN GENERAL AND FIVE
FIND THAT COMMON GROUND SO.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR EFFORTS HAVE
. THANK YOU MISS CAFE RESTAURANT
. YOUR QUESTION I'M JUST GOING
TO OF DUCK. INTO WHAT. OF COURSE
WAS TALK ABOUT. I I'LL AYE LIE.
YOUR OF LIKE WHAT YOU'RE TO DO
GET KIDS OUT. INTO INTO PARKS
AND ENDED OUT INTO NATURE AND
SEE SOME OF THAT. MAYBE THE MORE
FOCUSED IS- HOW FAR I THINK.
YOU'RE I PLAY ON THE SAME
WAVELENGTH LET'S NOT HURT THE
BUDGET LET'S TRY TO BALANCE IT
AS IT MOVES TOWARD IS THERE A
WAY THAT YOU AS YOU MOVE FORWARD
WITH YOUR BILL- IS TO HAVE A-
YOU INSERT SOMEPLACE. WHERE
THERE'S DIRECTION TO THE STATE
PARKS TO KEEP TRACK OF THIS. AMP
AND BRING BACK A REPORT TO THE
STATE NOT SOMETIME THE UPGRADE
IDEA SO THAT WE KNOW WHAT THE
ACTUAL BENEFICIAL VALUE. WAS
GAINED FROM OUR INVESTMENT IN
THIS OPPORTUNITY YEAH. I WILL
CERTAINLY DO THAT AND I WILL. I
WILL PURSUE CONVERSATIONS AND
PUSH THE IDEA. THAT YOU'VE
RAISED- I DEFINITELY THINK THESE
ARE JUST A TREMENDOUS ASSET AND
WHY DO WE CAPITALIZE ON IT- YOU
KNOW THEY'RE THEY'RE MADE TO BE
USED ENJOYED EXPERIENCED- AND-
YES WE HAVE BUDGETARY ISSUES AND
THAT'S NOT DE MINIMUS. BUT SO I
WILL. GOING TO ROUTE ALL WORKERS
STAFF ACTUALLY COME OF SOME
VERBIAGE WILL PUT AMEND
SUBSEQUENTLY- AS I MOVE THE BILL
ALONG BUT I WILL HAVE A
CONVERSATION WITH. OUR BUDGET
COLLEAGUES ON THAT I DON'T. M.
THANK YOU FOR THEIR ARREST
DISCUSSION I APPRECIATE MISTER
DOUGLAS COMMENT I WANNA MAKE
SURE IT DOESN'T COME TOO
BURDENSOME I'M NOT AND THAT'S
THAT'S ONE THING WE WANT TO WORK
WITH YOU ON JUST HOW HE CAN TRY
YES YES YES BUT I DO I THINK
IT'S INTERESTING YOU KNOW. AT
THE VICE CHAIR AND I SAID BIRD
ABOUT HOW MANY PEOPLE IS IT WE
DON'T KNOW WE'VE NEVER DONE THIS
RIGHT SO IT'S IMPORTANT TO KEEP
TRACK- I HAVE A QUESTION AS I
ALWAYS DO FROM YOU MISTER
COOLEY. THE REVIEWING THIS BILL
I LEARNED SOMETHING I DIDN'T
KNOW THAT SEPTEMBER NINTH WAS
THE DAY THAT CALIFORNIA BECAME A
STATE SO I UNDERSTAND YOU'RE
EFFORT HERE TO- TO ADD AN
ELEMENT OF HISTORY AS YOU ALWAYS
DO. BUT I GUESS PIGGYBACKING ON
WHAT MISS GARCIA WAS FOCUSED ON
WHICH IS EQUITY- I GUESS IF.
EVEN I. WE ALL WANTTO ACHIEVE
EQUITABLE ACCESS TO OUR PARKS
AND IT'S VERY MUCH WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO ACHIEVE HERE.
SEPTEMBER NINTH MOVES EVERY
YEAR. AND I GUESS I WOULD BE
CURIOUS WHETHER WOULD BE MORE.
MORE EQUITABLE TO PROVIDE THAT
ON A WEEKEND CONSISTENTLY VERSES
A DAY THAT MOVES. AND THEN WOULD
FALL ON DAYS WHEN PERHAPS YOU
KNOW OUR WORKERS THAT ARE
WORKING. YOU KNOW DURING. THE
WEEK WOULD NOT HAVE ACCESS TO
THIS BENEFIT CITY OF THOUGHT
FROM. YEAH I THINK. I'M OF. I'M
ALL FOR ACCESS SO I ACTUALLY DO
RECOGNIZE AT SEPTEMBER NINTH IS
JUST A DAY THAT LEAVES OUT
BECAUSE OF ITS SIGNIFICANCE IN
THE STATE- BUT I DO I WONDERED
ABOUT THAT MYSELF- IT ACTUALLY
MAY ALSO BE AT THE START OF THE
SCHOOL YEAR MIGHT BE AT A TIME
IN THE SUMMER COULD BE MORE
ADVANTAGEOUS SO- IT'S MORE IT'S
SORT OF A HOOK TO HANG THE IDEAL
- SOUL- YEAH I'M- I'LL SEE. THAT
I'M SURE I'M OPEN ON THAT TOO
YEAH YOU KNOW THE KEEPING THE
ENDED VIEW EQUITY AND A USEFUL
TIME- YEAH I COULD SEE ACTUALLY
IT IF IT WAS THE SAME WEEKEND
EVERY YEAR THAT WOULD. THAT
WOULD PROBABLY BE MORE EFFECTIVE
THAT WOULD GET TALKED ABOUT
PEOPLE REMEMBER. YOU KNOW MAYBE
THE FIRST SATURDAY IN A GIVEN
MONTH. YEAH SO I'VE GOT YOU KNOW
I AM MY RECOMMENDATION TODAY
WILL BE AND I AM HAPPY TO. FOR
IT BUT I THINK THAT WE HAVE SOME
WORK THAT WE CAN DO ON THIS BILL
TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE PROVIDING
THE MOST ACCESS TO THE MOST
CALIFORNIANS AND I KNOW YOU WILL
DO WORK DILIGENTLY- AND AGAIN
EVEN IF IT'S JUST A POINT WE
WORK TOWARDS THAT. PRESERVER
EXXON IDEAS I THINK YOU ALL
COLLEAGUES YEAH MISTER BENNETT
DID YOU HAVE. AT AS- AS WE- ARE
CONSIDERING MOVING TO A THREE
DAY WEEKEND. ONE THAT EVERYBODY
KNOWS KNOWS ABOUT- I JUST WANNA
GET ONE OTHER POINT OUT THAT THE
NUMBER OF STATE PARKS AND- OUR
STATE PARKS ARE RIGHT AT THE
BEACH. HEAVILY USED. LOTS OF
PEOPLE WANT TO ATTEND THOSE
PARKS I'M COMPLETELY SUPPORTIVE
OF- ASSEMBLY MEMBERS COMMENTS
ABOUT. LOW INCOME PEOPLE AND WHY
50% SO AS YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT
GOING FROM 50% TO. LOWER THAN
THAT AND YOU'RE ALSO TALKING IF
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT FREE. AND
IT'S A THREE DAY WEEKEND. I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE BASE WHERE WE
HAVE PEOPLE WITH HUGE. YOU KNOW.
SIX FIGURE TRAILER HOMES. AND
THEY'RE ALL VYING TO BE CAMPING
AT THE BEACH. AND OF. THOSE
PEOPLE WERE JUST VIEW THIS AS A
GREAT- IT'S THIS IS NOT AN
EQUITY ISSUE FOR. FOR THESE
PEOPLE I MEAN THIS IS. YOU KNOW
THE COMMISSIONERS SO I JUST WANT
TO I DON'T HAVE A SOLUTION TO
ALL OF THAT- BUT THINK OF
FOUGHT. I THINK YOU SHOULD KEEP
THAT IN MIND THAT THIS COULD BE
OVER. A REAL REVENUE ISSUE
AUTHORIZED. ON A THREE DAY
WEEKEND IF WE COULD FIND A WAY
TO MAKE IT. FREE FOR. A THAT I'D
BE WILLING MAKE IT FREE FOR LOW
INCOME KIDS COME FROM SCHOOLS IN
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES. ALL THE
TIME. IF WE TO COULD WITH S.
LIKE IT'S KIDS OUT WHEN IT'S
CONVENIENT FOR THEM EXCEPT- BUT
BE CAREFUL ABOUT SUBSIDIZING
JUST TO. YOU KNOW THAT THE POST
THE COASTAL BEACH PEOPLE WHO
DON'T NEED A SUBSIDY. AND THEY
GO HEY YEAH I CAN JUST SEE ME WE
ALREADY HAVE BATTLES OVER YOU
KNOW SIR TO GET GETTING THAT
CAMPSITE TO THAT. THAT CREATES A
REVENUE ISSUE BECAUSE ALL THAT
HEAVY DEMAND ON THE PARK. IS
EXPENSIVE SO JUST WANT TO GET
THAT OUT THERE FOR YOU GUYS TO.
WITH YOUR STAGE THOUGHTS ON THIS
BILL WILL KEEP THAT IN MIND
THANKS. FOR THANK YOU MISTER AND
MISTER. THANK YOU I'M- THIS. DAY
FEEL LIKE AND THAT WE CAN DO TO
MAKE ACCESS TO OUR PARKS JUST A
LITTLE BIT MORE AFFORDABLE. I
DON'T SEE THAT ANALYSIS TO ABOUT
HOW THAT ACTUALLY INDUCES
ADDITIONAL PARTICIPATION- AND
WHAT THAT MIGHT DO AS FAR AS THE
EXPENDITURES FOR- HEIGHTENED
ATTENDANCE AT PARKS- THAT WOULD
BE IMPORTANT BUT I THINK I FEEL
LIKE THIS IS A VALUE ADD. ON
THAT THERE ARE PEOPLE THAT
OTHERWISE MAY NOT BE ABLE TO-
YOU KNOW LOOK AT THAT TWENTY
DOLLAR MISSION FEE OR WHATEVER
IT MIGHT BE PER PERSON. THAT
WOULD BE PROHIBITIVE- THAT WOULD
BE ABLE TO GIVE THAT THEY GIVE
ACCESS AND LIKE HER CHAIR I
REALLY COMMEND YOU FOR REALLY
TOUGH TYING THAT INTO A MISSION
DAY. I WOULD ALSO RECOMMEND
PARTICULARLY FROM THE PARENTS OF
SCHOOL CHILDREN AS WELL DO YOU
DO- LOOK AT AT SOME WAY TO TRY
TO GET THAT THE OPTION FOR PARKS
SYSTEMS TO BE ABLE TO UTILIZE
THAT. SECOND SATURDAY OR SUNDAY
WITH IN SEPTEMBER YOU'RE AFTER
LABOR DAY WEEKEND SO THAT'S
GOOD- BUT YOU ARE ALSO YOU KNOW
MAY NOT BE. ON THAT WEDNESDAY.
ABLE TO ACKNOWLEDGE ON TO THAT
IS ON THE- THE TIME THAT WE ARE-
RECOGNIZING CALIFORNIA ADMISSION
DAY SO- I'M SURE THE BILL CAN
ENJOY SOME OF THOSE IMPROVEMENTS
BUT I FEEL CONFIDENT THIS WILL
BE OF VALUE ADD- YOU KNOW IN
THE- DESPITE. YOU KNOW- SOME OF
THE BUDGET THINGS THAT WE CAN
YOU KNOW WORK ON OVERTIME. THANK
YOU MISTER WARD. THREE WILL THE
BILL AS PRESENTED SECOND. CAT
MOTION A SECOND- AND I WANT TO
THANK YOU MR COOLEY AS THE
MOTHER OF A FOURTH GRADER WHO
PROBABLY HAS TAKEN AFTER MOUNT
DIABLO STATE PARK ON HER FOURTH
GRADE PARK PASS. AND YOU KNOW I
KNOW HOW IMPORTANT IT IS THAT WE
TEACH OUR CHILDREN TO BE
STEWARDS OF THE ENVIRONMENT
BECAUSE THEY ARE OUR FUTURE AND
SO IS OUR CLIMATE SO. PREACHY AT
THE BILL AND- WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. I JUST THANK YOU ACTUALLY
FOR THIS VERY ROBUST DISCUSSION
AND I WILL WORK WITH STAFF ON
HOW WE MIGHT STRUCTURE. A
REQUEST TO REPORT. SO NOT UNDULY
BURDENSOME. AND I WOULD JUST SAY
I WILL. TRY TO RAP IN SOME OF
THE OTHER IDEAS THAT FALL THE
REPORT SUGGESTION. THERE MAY BE
WAYS TO KIND OF. DO ONCE A
LITTLE BIT- R. I DON'T THINK
IT'S A STELLAR WORK MAKES SENSE
TO KIND OF- OURSELVES ON A
LEARNING CURVE. FOR ADVANCING. A
POLICY. AND TO GIVE OURSELVES
ROOM TO FLUSH IT OUT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. YEAH WE
FOLLOW. THE MOTION IS THE PAST
APPROPRIATIONS BARRICADE HANDBAG
BARRICADE HAND I. DALI DALI I
BENNETT SENATE I BIGELOW HI
BIGELOW I FRIEDMAN. GARCIA
GARCIA I KALRA LEVIN LEVINE I
MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI I KNOW
WHEN I RUBIO RUBIO AYE SALAS
SMITH SMITH I THE APPROVED WHAT
THE VALLAPUDUA I WARD WARD I
THINK MR PLAYED A BELFAST THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ALL INDICATIONS
THE MOTION NOW HONEST
PETRIE-NORRIS IS BILL AB SIXTEEN
FORTY FIVE. THANK YOU THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
LARA PLEASE. PARA QUE HAN I'VE
BEEN WORKING ON AYE DOLLY DALI I
BENNETT BENNETT I BIGELOW
BIGELOW AYE FRIEDMAN GARCIA
GARCIA I KALRA. LEVINE LEVINE I
RUBIO RUBIO AYE SALAS SMITH
SMITH I APPROVED WHAT THE
APPROVED BY I'M WARD MORE DIE.
HEY WE ARE WE WILL BE MOVING HER
INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON THIRTY
BY THIRTY BUT FIRST LET'S CALL
THE ROLL FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS
I FUNDS WE MENTIONED MISTER
SALAS WALK AND. THIS IS. A. I
REMEMBER. THE FIRST. LISTEN
BELOW CHILES UP THERE YEAH.
ELEVEN THIS IS THE CONSENT TO A
NINETEEN OH SIX ABSENT MEMBERS.
FRIEDMAN I KALRA. LEVINE LOW I
MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI I SELL
SALAS HI BE A GOOD ONE THE I
WORE OR I. THANK YOU. IN P.
TRAINER AB SIXTEEN FORTY FIVE AB
MEMBERS FREE FRIEDMAN I KALRA.
SALAS SALAS I. RECEIVE.
SO IF I FELT. IT GIPSON WITH YOU
. SO WE ARE NOW GOING TO MOVE WE
CAN. WE WILL CONTINUE TO A THE
ROLE OF A WORK WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE IN OUR INFORMATIONAL
HEARING ON CALIFORNIA'S THIRTY
BY THIRTY INITIATIVE. I WILL BE
MAKING SOME OPENING REMARKS AND
THEN WE'LL HAVE OUR PANELISTS
PRESENT AFTER THE PANELISTS
CONCLUDED WE WILL USE THE
MODERATE TELEPHONE SERVICE FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT AND HEAR PUBLIC
COMMENT FROM ANYONE HERE IN THE
ROOM. THE CALLING NUMBER FOR THE
HEARING AGAIN IF YOU WANT TO
CALL IN FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
DURING THE INFORMATIONAL HEARING
IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE
TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE AND THE PIN
IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
FOUR. AT PLEASE CALL. WHEN
YOU'VE HEARD THE LAST PANELISTS
HONORED. AND YOU WILL BE PER
TIMES. NOW WE'VE GOT OVER THE
LOGISTICS I WANT TO WELCOME THE
WITNESSES TO THE HEARING. AT AND
THANK THEM FOR BEFORE THE TO THE
AND OF CALIFORNIA IS VERY
IMPORTANT THIRTY BY THIRTY
INITIATIVE AND HOW IT IS
PROGRESSING. THIRTY BY THIRTY IS
AN EFFORT TO CONSERVE AND
PROTECT BIODIVERSITY CLIMATE
CHANGE IS. CLIMATE CHANGES
PUTTING OUR NATURAL HERITAGE AT
RISK LIKE NEVER BEFORE WE'RE
SEEING IT LIVE AND IN ACTION.
AND CALIFORNIA IS TAKING REAL
STEPS TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE. THE
THIRTY BY THIRTY EFFORT IS
INTENDED TO PROTECT OUR FISH AND
WILDLIFE SPECIES PROVIDE ACCESS
TO OPEN SPACE FOR CALIFORNIANS
AND REDUCE THE IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE. ON OUR NATURAL
AND WORKING LANDS. AND IF I
IMAGINE WE WILL HEAR FOUR
PANELISTS THIS IS AN AMBITIOUS
GOAL. AND THERE'S A LOT OF WORK
THAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN IS WE'RE
GONNA HIT THOSE GOALS BY TWENTY
THIRTY. GOVERNOR NEWSOM
ESTABLISHED A THIRTY BY THIRTY
GOAL FOR CALIFORNIA THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER IN OCTOBER OF
TWENTY TWENTY. AND RELEASED A
DRAFT PATHWAYS TO THIRTY BY
THIRTY STRATEGY IN DECEMBER OF
LAST YEAR WHICH OUR PANELISTS
WILL DISCUSS THIS MORNING. TO
DATE THE LEGISLATURE HAS NOT
PASSED LEGISLATION TO PROVIDE
DIRECTION OR PRIORITIES TO THE
STATE AND HOW TO ACHIEVE THE
GOALS THIRTY BY THIRTY. YET IT
IS OUR JOB TO. OVERSEE THIS
IMPORTANT RESPONSIBILITY AND THE
FUTURE CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE. WE
MUST ENSURE THAT STATE MEETS THE
GOALS AND DOES SO IN A WAY THAT
IS OPEN AND TRANSPARENT. AND
ACCOUNTABLE TO THE CITIZENS OF
CALIFORNIA. I THIS IS FIRST OF
SEVERAL HEARINGS AS THE STATE
WORKS FOR THE THIRTY BY THIRTY
GOAL WE WILL CONTINUE TO OVERSEE
THIS PROCESS AND ENSURE THAT WE
ARE MOVING. TOWARDS THESE GOALS
AND WE ACHIEVE THEM. I'M EXCITED
TO HEAR FROM THE PANELISTS AND
FOR ROBUST DISCUSSION THIS
MORNING. WITH ANY OTHER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS LIKE TO
PROVIDE OPENING COMMENTS BEFORE
WE BEGIN. MISTER KALRA. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SHARE- I- WHO WAS
VERY PROUD TO INTRODUCED AB
THIRTY THIRTY A COUPLE YEARS AGO
AND ALTHOUGH IT DIDN'T MAKE THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ACTION AND I'M REALLY
NOT ONLY SPURRED FURTHER ACTION
FROM US LEGISLATURE AND FROM OUR
DEPARTMENTS BUT EVEN THE OF THE
WHITE HOUSE SAYS THE BY
ADMINISTRATION HAS TAKEN A CUE-
ONCE AGAIN- FROM CALIFORNIA'S
LEADERSHIP AND SOME VERY
GRATEFUL. THAT THIS COMMITTEE
AND- OUR LEGISLATURES
CONTINUING- THE LEADERSHIP- IN
TERMS OF PROTECTING OUR LAND
WATER YOU. THANK MISTER KALRA
DISCUSS. I JUST WANT ONE WANNA
COMMAND OUR COLLEAGUES
LEADERSHIP ON THE THIRTY BY
THIRTY INITIATIVE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION- AS WELL AND
YOURSELF FOR BRINGING ATTENTION
TO THE PART OF THE WORK OF
MAKING SURE WE HAVE DETAILS
BEHIND THIS IS THAT WE CREATE A
PROGRAM THAT MEETS ITS GOALS AND
WE TO SCHOOLS FOR ALL CALIFORNIA
THAT TO SOME CALIFORNIANS I'M
INTERESTED TO HEAR THOUGH TO
THIS PRESENTATION A FEW THAT
PEACH REPRESENTATIONS. ABOUT HOW
WE INSURE THIS IS HAPPENING BOTH
IN REAL COMMUNITIES AND URBAN
COMMUNITIES TO LIKE THE ONE I
REPRESENT I HAVE A VERY DENSE
DISTRICT- AND THERE ARE SOME
OPPORTUNITIES OUT THERE BUT AS
WE'RE DOING THIS THIRTY BY
THIRTY CALL I HOPE THAT WERE
OPEN TO GETTING CREATIVE WHETHER
IT'S THROUGH BROWNFIELD WHETHER
IT'S THROUGH MAY. OF OPEN SPACE
WITH AFFORDABLE HOUSING THE
REALITIES THAT WE DON'T HAVE A
LOT LEFT AND SO IF WE'RE GONNA
PARTAKEN IN THIS WORK WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO BE OPEN TO-
DEFENDED COMING TOGETHER AND IN
THE SAME SPACE AND SO INTERESTED
TO HEAR FROM THE ADMINISTRATION
ON THAT AND SO I APPRECIATE THAT
YOU ARE PUTTING A BIGGER
SPOTLIGHT ON THIS. THANK YOU
MISS GARCIA ONE OF. WHEN I CALL
YOUR COMMENTS YOU MISTER KALRA
FOR KEEPING THIS OF MIND THE
LARGEST AND THINK ONE OF THE
CRITICAL REASONS TO DO THIS IS
TO BRING THE VOICES THAT EACH OF
US REPRESENT EVERY. TO THIS
CONVERSATION AND MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYONE IS LISTENING TO THIS
IMPORTANT VOICES THAT WE ALWAYS
BRING TO BEAR AS WE REPRESENT
OUR CONSTITUENTS- WE'RE GOING TO
TURN OUR PRESENTERS AND JUST ONE
SECOND BUT- WE WILL ALLOW US TO
POWER TO. VOTE ON THE BILLS
BEFORE WE DO SO WILL- CALL THE
ROLL BOTH ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR AB NINETEEN OH SIX DOWN
ABSENT MEMBERS KALRA KALRA I. A.
B. SIXTEEN FORTY FIVE BETWEEN.
ABSENT MEMBER KALRA. KALRA I. AB
TWENTY ONE TWENTY EIGHT COOLEY
ABSENT MEMBERS KALRA KALRA I
THANK HIM SO NOW OFFICIALLY
DURING THE BILL HEARING AND
MOVED TO THE INFORMATIONAL
HEARING WITH THAT I WANT TO TURN
IT OVER TO OUR FIRST PRESENTER
DR JENNIFER. AT NORRIS DEPUTY
FOR BIODIVERSITY AND AT THE CAL
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY. THANK
JENNIFER IS GOING TO BE ON THE
WEBEX LET'S SEE. GOOD MORNING
FROM FOCUSING. YES I AM. I
SHOULD BE ON THE WEBEX- YOU ARE
OKAY WE DON'T SEE YOU MISTER
SENATE NOW. OF IF THAT WAS
PROBABLY OUR TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES. PEOPLE WANT WE CAN
GET SECOND WITH YOUR I DO HAVE
THE POWER SO I OKAY GIVE A ONE
THEY'RE TRYING TO THERE YOU ARE
WE SEE A- ALL RIGHT. I'M GOING-
SEE IF THE SCREEN. WORKS THAT'S
PART OF IT- CHALLENGE A SECOND.
THAT WORKS. YOUR POWERPOINT FOR
YOUR GOLDEN. BUT NOW I CAN'T SEE
MY OWN NOTES WHICH IS ALWAYS A
CHALLENGE HOLD ON A SECOND. WILD
I DON'T LIKE WEBEX- WELL GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE OF THE COMMITTEE I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK HERE TODAY I'M JOINED BY
MARK GOLD- DEPUTY SECRETARY FOR
COAST AND OCEANS AND- EXECUTIVE
. A DIRECTOR OF THE OCEAN
COUNCIL. ONE SECOND IF I DO THAT
DO YOU SEE MY FULL SCREEN OR DO
YOU SEE MY NOTES NO WE DON'T
HEAR NOTES WE JUST POWER POINT
SO IF THAT HELPS YOU GO. YEAH I
DO REALLY MY NOTES THAT WOULD
HELP OKAY. I THINK I'M GOOD NOW
. THIS IS A CONFUSING SYSTEM
OKAY ANYWAY I'M HERE TO TALK
TODAY ABOUT THIRTY BY THIRTY
VERY EXCITED ABOUT READING IF
YOU'RE NOT JUST GOING ON TOP OF
THE SLIDE IF YOU CLICKED ON.
WELL THAT'S A BIGGER BOX. THERE
YOU GO. ONE MORE FERRY ARE NOW
WE SEE IT. ONE IS GOING TO DO IT
WITHOUT MY NOTES BECAUSE I'VE
DONE THIS TALK A MILLION TIMES
AND HOPEFULLY HAVE A TOUCHING
ALL THE MAIN POINTS THAT I WANT
TO- I'M REALLY EXCITED HERE TO
TALK TO YOU TODAY ABOUT THIRTY
BY THIRTY. I APPRECIATE ALL OF
YOUR OPENING REMARKS VERY
HELPFUL- AND APPRECIATE THE
SUPPORT THIS IS BEEN A GREAT
YEAR- AND I WILL TELL RIGHT. SO
AS YOU- BY THIRTY WAS
ESTABLISHED BY. GOVERNOR
NUISANCE NATURE BASICALLY.
EXECUTIVE ORDER AND OCT. OF
TWENTY TWENTY. THIS EXECUTIVE
ORDER IS ACTUALLY BROADER. HAS A
OF A- VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
INITIATIVES EMBEDDED WITHIN IT
BUT THE ONE THAT DEFINITELY GETS
A LOT OF THE ATTENTION IS OUR
COMMITMENT TO CONSERVE 30% OF
OUR LANDS AND COASTAL WATERS BY
TWENTY THIRTY. AND THAT
EXECUTIVE ORDER DIRECTED THE
CALIFORNIA NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY TO DEVELOP A STRATEGY FOR
ACHIEVING THIRTY BY THIRTY. AND
TO DO SO WHEN. ROBUST INCLUSIVE
PUBLIC ENGAGEMENT- AND I'M VERY
EXCITED TO TELL YOU THAT. THAT
IS WHAT WE DID OVER THE LAST
YEAR. WE HAD A LOT IN TOTAL
SEVENTEEN WORKSHOPS IN A YEAR
WHICH I THINK IS POTENTIALLY
UNPRECEDENTED. AND WE DID IT IN
A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT WAYS
BECAUSE OF COURSE WE'RE ON ZOOM
AND COULDN'T BE WITH PEOPLE IN
PERSON. BUT WE HELD- NINE
REGIONAL WORKSHOPS MOVING AROUND
THE STATE TO ASK DIFFERENT-
PEOPLE WHAT. KINDS OF
CONTRIBUTION. THERE ARE IN
DIFFERENT- REGIONS OF THE STATE
WHAT ARE THE CHALLENGES WHAT
WORKS WHEN IT COMES TO
CONSERVATION STRATEGIES. WE HAVE
FIVE DIFFERENT TOPICAL WORKSHOPS
WHERE WE BROUGHT IN EXPERTS ON
DIFFERENT TOPICS AND ASKED FOR
THEIR THOUGHTS. AND THEY
PRESENTED A WHITE PAPER WHICH
THEN WE SOLICITED PUBLIC
FEEDBACK- TO THAT WHITE PAPER SO
IT'S SORT OF AN ONLINE FORUM AND
DISCUSSION AND WE DID THAT FOR.
TOPICS AROUND EQUITY CLIMATE
CHANGE HOW TO PROTECT
BIODIVERSITY AS WELL AS- HOW WE
DEFINE CONSERVATION FOR THE
PURPOSES OF THIRTY BY THIRTY. WE
HAD AN ONLINE QUESTIONNAIRE-
WHERE WE SOLICITED INPUT FROM
FOLKS THAT WAS SIMILAR TO WHAT
WE ASK FOR IN THE REGIONAL
WORKSHOPS. WE'VE HAD OVER
SEVENTY TRIBAL CONSULTATIONS ON
CONVERSATIONS WE RECEIVED OVER
ONE THOUSAND LETTERS OVER FOUR
THOUSAND PEOPLE ARE HONEST OUR-
KNOWING. I COULD GO ON IT WAS A
REALLY ROBUST YEAR FRIEDMAN
ADVISORY COMMITTEE THAT REVIEWED
OUR DRAFT MADE PUBLIC MEETINGS
SINCE THEN AND WE STILL HAVE A
WEBSITE CALIFORNIA NATURE DOT CA
DOT GOV. FOR ALL THE INFORMATION
ALL THE WORKSHOPS ALL THE WHITE
PAPERS ARE HOUSED. TO LOTS OF
ROBUST PUBLIC FEEDBACK WHICH HAS
JUST BEEN TREMENDOUSLY VALUABLE. FOR DEVELOPING OUR DRAFT
DOCUMENT. SO DID ISSUE DRAFT.
DOCUMENT CALLED PATHWAYS TO
THIRTY BY THIRTY AND I'M GOING
TO WALK YOU THROUGH THAT. WE
RELEASED IN DECEMBER OUR COMMENT
PERIOD CLOSED IN ON FEBRUARY
FIFTEENTH SO JUST A FEW WEEKS
AGO WE'VE BEEN INCORPORATING ALL
THE GREAT FEEDBACK WE GOT FROM
THE PUBLIC- AGAIN CLOSE TO A
THOUSAND LETTERS- SOME OF WHICH
WERE QUITE LONG SO VERY VERY
HELPFUL- INFORMATION THAT WE'RE
INCORPORATING. SORT BY STAR. IS
ORGANIZED- AROUND SORT OF A FEW
MAIN SECTIONS THE FIRST IS OUR
CONSERVATION FRAMEWORK- WITH
THREE KEY OBJECT FOR ACHIEVING
THIRTY BY THIRTY. FIRST PROTECT
BIODIVERSITY THIS IS REALLY A
CROWDED IN THE INTERNATIONAL
MOVEMENT FOR THIRTY BY THIRTY
IT'S REALLY FUNDAMENTALLY ABOUT
MAKING SURE THAT. THE PLANTS AND
ANIMALS THAT WE RELY ON FOR OUR
ECOSYSTEM SERVICES- ARE. ARE
EGGS CAN PERSIST ACROSS THE
GLOBE. WE'VE COURSE ALSO KNOW
pCAN EXPAND. TO NATURE AND
PROVIDE MORE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PEOPLE TO EXPERIENCE OF THE
OUTDOORS. AND OUR LANDS CAN BE
USED TO MEDICATE- OF SEQUESTER
CARBON AND BUILD RESILIENCE TO
THE EFFECTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE SO
THESE ARE THREE KEY OBJECTIVES.
WE ALSO THREE CORE COMMITMENTS
THAT REALLY SHOULD GOVERN
EVERYTHING THAT WE DO- AS WE
IMPLEMENT THE STRATEGY WE WANT
TO WORK TO ADVANCE JUSTICE
EQUITY DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION.
ALWAYS TO STRENGTHEN OUR TRIBAL
PARTNERSHIPS. AND IN THE CONTEXT
OF DURING OUR CONSERVATION
PROTECT OUR ACADEMIC PROSPERITY
OUR CLEAN ENERGY RESOURCES AND
OUR FOOD SUPPLY. WE PUT FORWARD
A DEFINITION FOR WHAT OUR THIRTY
BY THIRTY CONSERVATION AREAS SO
HOW WE WILL COUNT TO THIRTY WE
HAVE TO DEFINE WHAT WE'RE
COUNTING. SO THIS IS THE
DEFINITION WE PUT OUT IN OUR
DRAFT LAND AND COASTAL WATER
AREAS THAT ARE DURABLY PROTECTED
AND MANAGED TO SUPPORT
FUNCTIONAL ECOSYSTEMS BOTH
INTACT AND RESTORED AND THE
SPECIES THAT RELY ON THEM. SO
REALLY TWO PIECES OF OUR
DEFINITION THE PLACE SHOULD BE
PROTECTED FOR- FUNCTIONAL
ECOSYSTEMS FOR BIODIVERSITY AND
THAT PROTECTION SHOULD BE
DURABLE. WHEN IT COMES TO LANDS
ARE 24% OF CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY
MEETS THAT DEFINITION AND THIS
REALLY SHOWS UP ACROSS A BROAD
RANGE OF USES AND LANDSCAPES
THIS INCLUDES DEDICATED
CONSERVATION AREAS. RECREATIONAL
LANDS AND OPEN SPACES AND A FAIR
NUMBER ARE WORKING LANDS THAT
ARE UNDER CONSERVE EASEMENT FOR
CONSERVATION VALUES BUT CONTINUE
TO PROVIDE. YOU KNOW GRAZING OR
OR- TIMBER IT A SUSTAINABLE WAY
. WE ALSO AND- IN EVERYTHING
ABOUT THESE LANDS THE IMPORTANCE
OF ALL CONSERVATION TO THE
FUNCTIONING OF THESE SORT OF
SPECIAL CONSERVATION AREAS AND
THAT THEY EXIST IN A BROADER
MATRIX OF- CONSERVATION EFFORTS
THAT ARE EQUALLY IMPORTANT. I'M
GONNA TURN THE SCREEN OVER TO
MARK GOAL HE'S GONNA TALK LITTLE
BIT ABOUT- FROM THE PLAYS OUT IN
OUR COASTAL WATERS MARK. DR
NORRIS ON. ON THE CONSERVATION
OF COASTAL WATERS- YEAH BUT A
FEW THINGS SORT OF WORKING AT
THE SAME TIME ON. WE HAVE MARINE
PROTECTED AREAS WHICH ACCOUNT
FOR ABOUT 16% OF COASTAL WATERS
ON YOUR OPTIC CALIFORNIA. OUR
NETWORK OF MARINE PROTECTED
AREAS THAT TWENTY FOUR MPAS. ON
IS A NETWORK IT'S REALLY SAD AND
- GLOBALLY AND NOT FIRST. WHERE
IN THE MIDST OF A DECADE- REVIEW
OF THAT NETWORK AND SO WE HAVE
WE HAVE PROMISED. STAKEHOLDERS
ON ALL SIDES THAT- WE WON'T MAKE
ANY RECOMMENDATIONS ON MODIFYING
THE MPA NETWORK ON INTEL THE
CATTLE REVIEW IS. WHICH WILL BE-
ON THE FIRST QUARTER OF NEXT
YEAR. I'M AND THEN WHAT'S HAVING
. ABOUT EMPTY- AND WHETHER THERE
SHOULD BE A MODIFICATION OR NOT-
ON THAT. TURNING YOUR CALL I
THINK OKAY SO WHAT DO GET
ADDITIONAL- FOURTEEN AND JUST AS
A REMINDER TO EVERYBODY. MPAS
ARE NOT ALL NO TAKE ON AREAS I
THINK THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
FOR EVERYONE TO KNOW. ON A LOT
OF THEM ARE ARE CON. FOCUSED ON
WHICH WOULD ALLOW SOME
COMMERCIAL TAKE. OR MARC.
RECREATIONAL TAKE THE ON WHICH
M. P. EIGHT S. AND SO ON THAT
THAT FROM 9% ARE NO TAKE AND 7%
ARE ON. OUR CONSERVATION BASED
JUSTICE FOR BACK PROPERTY. BODY
SO I'M GETTING A THIRD- WHAT WE
TALKED IS THE- OF REALLY. OUR
WERE TO- WITH THE GOVERNMENT IS
THE AND I NORA- OBVIOUS- THE BY
MINISTRATION HIS MAY US. SO OF
PLAN. ON THIRTY THIRTY ARMS WE
HAVE A GREAT OPPORTUNITY WORKING
WITH THEM ON ASPEN SANCTUARIES.
FIVE NAZARIAN REYES ARE LED ON
BY NOW WHAT IN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT- THEY MAKE UP.
CURRENTLY MORE THAN 40% OF OUR
COASTAL WATERS AWAY OVER THIRTY.
FIVE ENDS AND I YOU HAVE A
STAKEHOLDER- BASED MANAGEMENT
ARRANGEMENT WHERE THE STATE IS
VERY HEAVILY INVOLVED ALL
STAKEHOLDER GROUPS ARE INVOLVED
BUT IT'S FISHING COMMUNITY
ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY BUSINESS
INSIDER. ON OUR ARE PART OF THIS
NATIONAL MARINE SANCTUARIES
EFFORT IT'S WHAT WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT ON POTENTIAL MOVING
FORWARD IN THIS PATHWAY DOT. ON
TO- WOULD TO DO AND- SANK
DISTRICT STRENGTHENING
CONSERVATION BETTER MEET THE
DEFINITION THE DOCTOR NORTH
TALKED ABOUT EARLIER. AND THOSE
WOULD INCLUDE- THINGS TO
CONSIDER WOULD BE STRENGTHENING
OUR QUALITY AND INVASIVE
SPECIES- PROTECTION AND SEED
BASSIL REDUCTION. ON PROTECT-
MARINE MAMMALS ON ENHANCE
DURABILITY OF EXISTING CON.
BASED FISHERIES MAN APPROACHES.
WATSON OR TO MATCH APPROACH IS
LIKE WITH DIFFERENT THIS CALL.
AND THE RAMP ON THOSE ARE SOME.
OF WHAT WE COULD BE DEALING
ANNOUNCEMENTS REYES SO NONE OF
THAT BEEN DETERMINED I'M REALLY
EXCITED ABOUT- WERE WITH- SAY.
AND THEN MEANS THANKS FOR MOVING
FORWARD ON DOING THAT I'M SEE
THERE'S THAT YOU MUST. REPUBLIC
JIM HERITAGE. THANKS REYES WELL.
ON IN WHICH LOTS OF
OPPORTUNITIES- TO REALLY DEVELOP
FURTHER WITHOUT BACK TO DR.
NORTH THANKS MARC. SO ARE MARK
MEANT THAT WE YOU KNOW WE HAVE
HAD ABOUT HOW A MILLION OF ONE
TO- GET TO THIRTY PER AND ABOUT
TO MILLION OF LAND AND HE I
DON'T SOME OF THE WAYS WE MIGHT
DO IN COASTAL WATERS IN OUR
PATHWAY DOCUMENT WE I. AS OF
PATHWAY TO THIRTY BY THIRTY I'M
GONNA TOUCH ON THESE HERE HERE
HERE ANY MENTION OF SOME OF WHAT
WE'RE THINKING OF IN THE COASTAL
WHY. SO FUNDAMENTAL WHY OF EXCEL
RE LAY CONS WE REALLY FOR ARE
ARE LOCAL PARTNER NO BEST WHERE
. CAN HAPPEN THEY'VE DONE THE
HARD WORK OF IDENTIFYING
IMPORTANT AREAS FOR COMMUNITIES
SO ONE OF EXELA BACK CONSERVE-
EXIT STRATEGICALLY ACQUISITIONS
BY ADDITIONAL TO ACQUIRE WE WANT
TO INCREASE BOB CONSERVATION
EASEMENTS ENHANCE CONSERVATION
OF EXISTING PUBLIC LANDS AND
WATERS AS MARK WAS TALKING ABOUT
OF COURSE WE HAVE LOTS OF
OPPORTUNITIES AS WELL WITHIN OUR
FEDERAL OTHER FEDERAL LANDS LIKE
FORESTS OF THE FISH AND WILDLIFE
SERVICE IT'S ULTRA WE WANT TO
INSTITUTIONALIZE ADVANCE
MEDICATION WE THINK THIS IS A
REALLY GREAT OPPORTUNITY TO
ADVANCE CONSERVATION BY- MORE
STRATEGICALLY- USING MEDICATION
ACROSS OUR LANDSCAPE
PARTICULARLY FOR LARGE
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS- PLACING
THAT MITIGATION IN PLACES THAT
WE MOST NEED IT AND IN IN WAYS
THAT ARE MORE STRATEGIC. ONE OF
AND EXCEL IN BAR RESTORATION WE
CAN'T JUST PROTECT OUR WAY OUT
OF THE BIODIVERSITY CRISIS WE
NEED TO RESTORE- IMPORTANT
LANDSCAPES- WE WANT TO
STRENGTHEN OUR COORDINATION
AMONG GOVERNMENTS AND KEY
PARTNERS THIS IS REALLY SPEAKING
TO OUR OPPORTUNITY TO LEVERAGE
FUNDSAND RESOURCES WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AS WELL AS
WITH TRAVEL PARTNERS. HOPEFULLY
ALL SAW THE EXCITING
ANNOUNCEMENT ON FRIDAY THAT WE
LIKE TO INVEST A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN TRIBAL RELATIONSHIPS
TO ADVANCE CONSERVATION- WITH
THEM. WE WANT TO OUR INVEST WERE
ABOUT INTERNALLY EXTERNALLY TO
REALLY MAXIMIZE OUR CONSERVATION
BENEFITS LOOK FOR WAYS THAT ALL
OF OUR DIFFERENT GRANTS AND BOND
PROGRAMS CAN WORK TOGETHER MORE
SYNERGISTICALLY WITH OUR
EXTERNAL- FUNDING OPPORTUNITIES.
I FINALLY- WE REALLY NEED TO
EVALUATE CONSERVATION OUTCOMES
AND MAKE SURE WERE ADAPTIVELY
MANAGING AND STEWARDING THOSE
PLANS FOR THE FUTURE. SO THE
DOCUMENT GOES THROUGH ALL THESE
PATHWAYS AND IDENTIFIES KEY NEXT
STEP ACTIONS THAT NEED TO BE
TAKEN. ANOTHER GREAT THING
THAT'S HAPPENING AS PART OF OUR
INITIATIVE IS A WE HAVE CREATED-
WHAT WE CALL CA NATURE ARE
GEOGRAPHIC INFORMATION SYSTEM
THIS IS AN ONLINE SUITE OF
INTERACTIVE MAPPING TOOLS. THAT
GO FROM VERY ACCESSIBLE TO
SOMEONE WHO DOESN'T KNOW GIS TO
EXTREMELY WONKY IF YOU LOVE TO
PLAY WITH DATA- THIS IS ONLINE
AT CALIFORNIA NATURE DOT CA DOT
GOV- FUNDAMENTALLY THIS ALLOWS
US TO. AND SEE ALL TOGETHER IN
THE SAME MAP WHERE ARE THESE
KIND. AREAS AND WHERE ARE THERE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR US TO ADVANCE
MORE CONSERVATION MAYBE BY-
CONNECTING TO OTHER EXISTING
PLACES ARE BUILDING WILDLIFE.
FOR EXAMPLE WE PROVIDE- OVERLAYS
OF WHERE BIODIVERSITY. ARE WHAT
THE PROJECTED OF CLIMATE
CONDITIONS WILL BE AS WELL AS
WHERE WE HAVE ACCESS- WHERE
WE'RE PROTECTED AREAS HAVE
ACCESS- FOR THE PUBLIC. SO WE
REALLY THINK THIS IS GOING TO BE
A GREAT PLACE FOR PEOPLE TO HAVE
COVER. ABOUT HOW WE CAN ADVANCE
THIRTY BY THIRTY TOGETHER AND
SPEAK A COMMON LANGUAGE. AS I
ALLUDED TO REALLY SEE- THIRTY BY
THIRTY AS HAPPENING ON THE
GROUND WE REALLY WANT TO EMPOWER
PARTNERS WHO ARE EXTREMELY
EXCITED ABOUT THIS INITIATIVE.
SO WE SEE REGIONAL COALITIONS
REGIONAL EFFORTS AS SORT OF THE
CORE OF THE WORK WE WANT TO DO.
OUR PARTNERSHIP OBVIOUSLY WOULD
INCLUDE TRAVEL PARTNERS. WE'VE
BEEN WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BIODIVERSITY COUNCIL
WHICH HAS BEEN AROUND SINCE THE
NINETEEN NINETIES WHICH IS A
COALITION OF FEDERAL STATE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THAT ARE
WORKING TOGETHER ON BIODIVERSITY
SINCE THE BY DEMONSTRATION
COMMITTED TO THIRTY BY THIRTY WE
SEE THIS AS A GREAT. SPACE
IDENTIFY WAYS TO WORK TOGETHER
WITH OUR FEDERAL PARTNERS AND
IDENTIFY UP. FOR CONSERVE. WE
ALSO- ARE WORKING WITH THE K.
BIODIVERSE NETWORK WHICH IS A-
CONSORTIUM OF ACADEMICS AND
PRACTITIONERS WERE THINKING
ABOUT THE KEY SCIENCE AND
MONITORING QUESTIONS- THAT WE
NEED TO EXPLORE TO REALLY MAKE
SURE THIRTY BY THIRTY IS MEETING
OUR KEY OBJECTIVES. AND THEN
FUNDAMENTALLY WITHIN CALIFORNIA
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY
OBVIOUSLY WE WANT TO USE OUR
DEPARTMENTS AND CONSERVANCY IS
TO HELP ADVANCE THIRTY BY
THIRTY. SO WE'VE SEEN THIS
CONSTELLATION OF GROUPS AS
REALLY HELPING US GET THE WORK
DONE. AS YOU WILL RECALL THERE
ARE SOME REALLY IMPORTANT
INITIAL INVESTMENTS AVAILABLE
THAT ARE GOING TO HELP US JUMP
START THIS EFFORT. THERE'S THE
NATURE BASED SOLUTIONS SET ASIDE
FROM LAST SUMMER SEVEN HUNDRED
SIXTY EIGHT MILLION. FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION IN COASTAL.
FUNDS WHICH WE THINK A LOT OF
THAT WILL HELP ADVANCE OUR
THIRTY BY THIRTY EFFORT. THERE'S
OVER SIX HUNDRED MILLION IN
HABITAT RESTORATION FUNDS ONE
HUNDRED FIVE MILLION WILDLIFE
QUARTERS WE REALLY THINK WERE
MORE WELL POSITIONED TO GET
GOING ON IMPLEMENTING THIS.
STRATEGY WE'RE EXCITED TO GET
THAT UNDER WAY. AND WITH THAT
I'LL STAY SHARING AND SEE IF YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FOR US THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR ATTENTION.
THANK DR NORRIS MR GOLD'S.
ANYONE WHEN. I THINK THAT IS THE
GROWTH OF THE PRESENT I THINK MR
GOLDWYN THE METAL DO WE HAVE WE
ARE MYSTICAL TO PRESENTATION
RIGHT. YEAH I GOT TO GO TO TALK
ABOUT THE HOST THAT'S RIGHT OKAY
WE'RE JUST CHECKING IN. GOT A
QUESTION ALBERTANS ON CLOSER.
OKAY PUT WAS GONNA GO. CHAU SIR
THANK YOU ON COUPLE QUESTIONS.
AS WE BY UP DIALED BIO.
BIODIVERSITY NETWORK. I WE WERE
LOOKING AT- WHEN THE INITIATIVE
WAS LAUNCHED THERE WERE A LOT OF
KICK- COMMITMENTS TO PURSUE
VOLUNTARY CONVERSATIONS ACTIONS
IN A WORK HANDS HANDS IN GLOVE
WITH PRIVATE LANDOWNERS. BUT IN
LOOKING AT THE DRAFT SOME OF THE
TOOLS AND PRACTICES OF FARMERS
AND RANCHERS DO WILL NOT BE
COUNTED INTO THIRTY CALL 30%
GOAL I JUST HELPED SET UP
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS OF PAULA
POLLINATOR HABITAT PROGRAM. AT
THE C. D. F. THAT THAT WE HAVE
IMMEDIATELY IMMEDIATELY- BIO
DIVERSITY BENEFITS. WHY WON'T
THAT BE COUNTED AT. THAT'S A
GREAT QUESTION SOMEONE AT.
REMIND YOU THAT THE THIRTY BY
THIRTY INITIATIVE IS PART OF
THAT BROADER NATURE BASED
SOLUTIONS EXECUTIVE ORDER AND
THAT EXECUTIVE ORDER INTENDS TO
DRIVE ON ALL OF THESE REALLY
IMPORTANT EFFORTS THAT PROMOTE
BIODIVERSITY AND ADVANCE-
CLIMATE ACTION ON OUR NATURAL
AND WORKING LANDS SO. POLLINATOR
SO HEALTH WE'RE WITH FORMER AND
RANCHERS TO IDENTIFY SO TO
SUPPORT ARE SCOPING PLAN FOR
EXAMPLE THOSE ARE ALL
ENCAPSULATED IN THAT BROADER
EXECUTIVE ORDER THIRTY MAY
THIRTY IN SORT OF A SPECIAL CASE
THIS IS THE KIND OF CONSERVATION
THAT'S A LITTLE HIGHER LEVEL
BECAUSE IT HAS THAT DURING. AND
THAT- PRIORITY FOR ABOUT SO THE
WAY WE SEE IT IS- ADJACENT LAND
THAT MIGHT HAVE REALLY IMPORTANT
AND VALUABLE PRACTICES FOR
BIODIVERSITY THAT MAYBE THOSE
PROTECTIONS AREN'T TERRIBLE FOR%
ONE REASON OR ANOTHER THEY
CONTRIBUTE TO OUR BROADER
OBJECTIVES- EVEN IF THEY'RE NOT
SPECIFICALLY OF THE THIRTY BY
THIRTY AREAS THAT WERE COUNTING
. AND WE BELIEVE THAT THOSE
EFFORTS BE ADVANCED AS WELL AND
THAT'S WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION
IS DOING GOOD THANK YOU. AND I
YOUR QUESTION HISTORY OF A WIN
COME TO YOU YOU COME MORE. I CAN
MR WARD. THANK YOU DO YOU MIND
IF I TO QUESTION. THANK YOU I'M
NORTH YOU SO MUCH FOR PRESENT I
THINK HUMANS A LOT OF OUR
PARTNERS I'M VERY EXCITED FOR
THIS INITIATIVE AND
CONGRATULATIONS ON. ALL THE HARD
WORK THAT WENT INTO LAST YEAR
I'M REALLY LOOKING FOR WELL THIS
CONVERSATIONS CONTINUE-
PARTICULARLY- EXCITED FOR YOUR
FOCUS ON REGIONAL PARTICIPATION-
SAN DIEGO COUNTY IS ONE OF IF
NOT THE MOST BIODIVERSE-
COUNTIES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WE KNOW WE HAVE- THE
GREATEST NUMBER OF- PLANT
SPECIES NUMBER OF BIRD SPECIES
AND I'M SURE ELSEWHERE ON THE-
FLOOR AND FUNDED CHANGE THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF OTHER THINGS TO
CELEBRATE- AND I AM HOPING THAT
AS YOU ARE DEVELOPING THIS GOAL
SETTING AND YOU ARE HEADING
TOWARDS YOU KNOW SORT OF YOUR
SIX MILLION. ACRE OF- TARGET-
THAT THAT WE DOING OUR BEST TO
MAKE SURE THAT IS PROPORTIONAL
OF. THAT I GOALS PROPORTIONALLY
ACHIEVE STATEWIDE SO THAT I SAW
ON ON THE STATE MY MAP THE HEAD
OVER THERE OBVIOUSLY A LOT OF
EXISTING NATIONAL PARKS AND
STATE PARKS AND OTHER CONSERVE
LANDS THAT'S GREAT THAT WE'VE
DONE THAT TO DEAN- BUT- THAT WE
DON'T. GET TO A STATEWIDE- GOAL
THAT SOMEHOW CONCENTRATES THAT-
IN IN CERTAIN AREAS THAT WERE
REALLY MAKING SURE THROUGH THAT
REGIONAL PARTICIPATION THAT WE
ARE ACHIEVING THAT BECAUSE WE
HAVE A LOT OF INTEREST THERE I'M
WONDERING- FOR SOME OF OUR
LOCAL- CONSERVE LANES DEDICATED
LANDS I MEAN C. P. TERRITORY IS
THAT ALSO SOMETHING THAT WOULD
FILTER. THE SORT OF- THE- THE
ACHIEVEMENT OR OR THE FOR THE
REGISTERING OF. OF WHETHER NOT
WERE MEETING THAT GOAL. YEAH
ABSOLUTELY YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION- SO YOU MENTION- IT
SEEMS. AND NCC PIECE OF THESE
APPLICANTS CONSERVATION PLANS
AND HABITAT CONSERVATION PLANS.
YOU KNOW I SEE THOSE KIND OF THE
GOLD STANDARD FOR IDENTIFYING
WHERE WE SHOULD DO CONSERVATION
NEXT AND COMMUNITY DRIVEN
CONSERVATION. OF COURSE THERE'S
LOTS OF OTHER STRATEGIES THAT
GET US TO THE AND SIMILAR KINDS
OF PRIORITIES- BUT WE DO
IDENTIFY IN THE PATHWAYS
DOCUMENT THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS
REGIONAL APPROACH AND- ENSURING
THAT THESE PLANS. ARE COMPLETED
AS WELL AS IN- PROVIDING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND SUPPORT
FOR THE PLACES THAT DON'T HAVE
THOSE PLANS SO THAT WE CAN
ACHIEVE- MORE REGIONAL
CONSERVATION THROUGHOUT THE
STATE IN OTHER PARTS OF THE
STATE OR THAT ARE. REALLY WELL
RESOURCE AND THEY'VE THEY'VE GOT
A LOT OF PLANS ANOTHER PLACE
THEY DON'T HAVE ANY AND WE'D
LIKE TO SEE- CAPACITY SUPPORT TO
HELP PEOPLE- DEVELOP THAT WORK.
ELSEWHERE IN THE STATE THANK YOU
I KNOW SAN DIEGO PARTNERS ARE
VERY EXCITED ABOUT THIS I WOULD
LOVE TO BE ABLE TO IMPLEMENT
THAT AND SORT OF MEET OUR
PROPORTION AT LEAST ARE
PROPORTIONAL GOAL- IN OUR REGION
AS WELL SO- THANK YOU FOR-
TURNING YOUR ATTENTION TOWARDS
REGIONAL COLLABORATION WHERE
WE'RE READY FOR THAT- SECONDLY.
I IC THROUGHOUT THE REPORT ON
THAT THERE IS AN INTEREST IN
COOPERATING TRADITIONAL
ECOLOGICAL KNOWLEDGE I KNOW
YOU'RE AWARE OF INTRODUCED AB.
TWENTY TO TWENTY FIVE WHICH JUST
RECENTLY PASSED OUT OF OUR
ASSEMBLY NOT RESOURCES COMMITTEE
THAT WILL WORK WITH THAT NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY TO TRY TO MAKE
SURE THAT IS CODIFIED POLICY.
THAT- I APPRECIATE BEING HE'S
BEEN IT HAD- AND THAT THE
DIALOGUE WITH OUR TRIBAL I'M
PARTNERS- AND THAT- AND I'M VERY
EXCITED ABOUT THE ANNOUNCEMENT
LAST WEEK- FOR THE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS SET ASIDE TO
HELP- TRANSITION SOME OF THOSE
LANDS BACK INTO THE CARE OF THE
FIRST PEOPLES- TO BE ABLE TO.
WORK ON THE STRATEGIES I IT'S A
TWO QUESTIONS ONE- WOULD. AND
YOU KNOW GOING FOR SEVERAL YEARS
YOU KNOW WHAT THAT TRANSFER OF
LAND- WERE TO GO BACK INTO- A
SOVEREIGN NATION TERRITORY
WITHOUT ALSO COUNT. TOWARD OUR
STATE GOALS- AND THEN SECONDLY
CAN YOU TALK A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT HOW TO U. K. AS A GENERAL.
ON HOW WE MANAGE LANDS. CAN
BENEFIT THE STATE IN AND- MAY.
CONSERVATION SO I THINK THAT
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION I
THINK THE FIRST QUESTION IS
REALLY AN IMPORTANT ONE TO HAVE
A DIALOGUE WITH- WITH THE TRAVEL
PARTNERS ABOUT HOW WE SHOULD
COUNT THEIR LANDS SO I THINK
CONCEPTUALLY OF COURSE THEY
BENEFIT OUR OVERALL OBJECTIVES-
BUT I'M ALSO SENSITIVE TO NOT
PUTTING OTHER. NATIONS LAND MAPS
SO WE'RE WE'RE WORKING THROUGH
THAT I THINK THAT'S A
CONVERSATION TO HAVE BUT I THINK
IN TERMS OF CONTRIBUTED THE
OVERALL OBJECTIVES OF
BIODIVERSITY CONSERVATION AND
CLIMATE RESILIENCE ABSOLUTELY-
AND WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT TEEKAY-
YOU KNOW ONE THING THAT IS.
OBVIOUS FROM ALL THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE HAD IS
THAT THERE ARE SOME. DEEP ARE
KNOWLEDGE ABOUT HOW BECAUSE
FUNCTION AND THAT WE HAVE SO
MUCH TO LEARN FROM OUR PART. AS
WE WORK TO MANAGE THESE LANDS
AND STORED THEM INTO THE FUTURE
SO YOU KNOW OUR INTEREST
ABSOLUTELY IS AND MAKING SURE
THAT THAT- THAT INFORMATION
SHARING THAT STAND IN A
RESPECTFUL WAY. CONTINUES AND
THAT WE BRING THAT KNOWLEDGE
INTO THE WORK THAT WE DO AND
THAT'S WHAT PART OF WHAT IS
ENVISIONED BY THIS- THE SENATE
SIDE IS REALLY TO CREATE A SPACE
WHERE THOSE CONVERSATIONS CAN
HAPPEN AND WHERE WE CAN. WHERE
WE CAN BUILD THAT UNDERSTANDING
. GREAT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
KEYRINGER MISTER BIGELOW IN THE
MISTER BENNETT. I THANK YOU TAKE
YOUR PRESENTATION- JUST HELP US
TO START OFF MAYBE GIVE US SOME
THE RUDIMENTARY LIKE
CALIFORNIA'S COMPRISED OF HOW
MANY ACRES. FIVE HUNDRED AND
FIVE FIVE SINCE THIS AT A
HUNDRED FOR BUT IT'S LESS TAKE A
HUNDRED AND FIVE AND GO WITH IT
SO OUT OF THAT PATTERN FIVE HOW
MANY ACRES THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ARE OWNED BY STATE
LOCAL AND FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. OR
CONTROLLED I THINK IN A WAY
THAT'S MANAGED OR PROTECTED
CURRENTLY. IT'S IN A 50% RANGE
VERY GOOD YEAH SO HAVE WE
ALREADY MET THE GOAL. OF
PRESERVING 50% OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. EXCEEDING BY TWENTY
MILLION ACRES THE GOVERNOR'S
ULTIMATE GOAL. WE'VE ALREADY
DONE IT NOW YOU'VE GOT TO GET
DOWN INTO YOUR MATRIX OF WHY
HAVE YOU DISCOUNT IT ALL OF
THOSE OTHER ACRES IN FACT LET'S
JUST SAY IT'S FORTY EIGHT
MILLION BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT'S
SENSIBLE TALLEST. OF THAT NUMBER
YOU'RE SAYING ONLY HALF OF THAT
QUALIFIES EXPLAIN TO US WHY HALF
IN FACT MORE THAN HALF OF THE
NATION'S PRETTIEST. NATIONAL
PARK YOU SOMEBODY IS NOT
INCLUDED. IN YOUR BILL. YOU
DON'T INCLUDE ALL OF YOU
SOMEBODY. IN YOUR FACTOR SO I
JUST WANT TO KNOW WHY A LOT OF
THINGS AREN'T REALLY ON THE
TABLE. AYE THAT'S SURPRISING TO
ME I WOULD NEED TO GO BACK AND
LOOK AT THE MAP IF THAT IS TRUE
I WAS SO WHEN I LOOK AT ALL THE
INFORMATION. YEAH I. I NEED TO
GO TO REPRESENT THE AERATION SO
THAT'S MY CONCERN. IT GOT IT'S
NOT A QUESTION IS JUST NO NO I
DON'T KNOW. SO THIS IS THIS IS
GOING TO GET WE DO BUT I WILL I
WILL TRY TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION
A COUPLE WAYS AND ALL OF THE
LOSE THE FRIEND- FIRST YOU KNOW
WE'RE NOT DISCOUNTING THE
IMPORTANCE OF ALL OF THE-
FEDERAL AND STATE LAND THAT IS
ALREADY. LARGELY YOU KNOW
MANAGEMENT HELD BY GOVERNMENTS
BUT MANY OF THOSE ARE MULTIPLE
USE LANDS AND THEY'RE NOT
PRIMARILY PROTECTING OUR
BIODIVERSITY AND WHAT THIRTY BY
THIRTY IS TRYING TO DO IS TO TRY
TO MOVE BEYOND- SOME OF THAT.
SOME OF THAT MANAGEMENT MAKE
SURE THAT WE'VE GOT THIS
PROTECTED PLACES THAT CONSERVE
OUR BRAND DIVERSITY AT
FUNDAMENTAL IT DOESN'T SAY THAT
THAT OTHER CONSERVATION IS AN
IMPORTANT IN FACT IF I GO BACK
TO MY EARLIER COMMENTS. THE
MAJOR IN WHICH THE CAN AREAS
EXIST IS VERY IMPORTANT AND HOW
THEY ARE MANAGED IS INCREDIBLY
HIGH VALUE. SO THAT'S ONE. WHEN
IT COMES TO THE MAPS- ONE THING
WE LEARNED SO WE USED- TO
EXISTING DATASETS TO BEGIN OUR
MAPPING EFFORT NICE IT BEGAN
BECAUSE THERE IS STILL WORK TO
BE DONE TO REFINE THESE MAPS
BUT- WE RELIED ON THE U. S.
GEOLOGICAL SURVEY THEY DID A
NATIONWIDE EVALUATION OF ALL. OF
PUBLICLY OWNED LAND FROM
WILDERNESS AREAS TO- BOAT RAMPS
AND CLASSIFIED THEM ACCORDING TO
THEIR LEVEL OF PROTECTION. SO
THESE FOR GAP CODES ONE TWO
THREE FOUR. AND WE SAID THAT WE
WOULD LIKE TO WE THINK CODE ONE
AND LARGELY MEET OUR DEATH.
HELLO HAS AN AN- DATA SAID
CALLED TE PROTECTIVE AIR
CALIFORNIA PROTECTED AREAS
DATABASE SO IT STEPS DOWN FROM
THIS USGS CLASSIFICATION. AND
THAT- MAPS ALL THE DIFFERENT
OPEN SPACES ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
AND WHAT WE FOUND WHEN WE PUT
THOSE MAPS OUT DURING OUR DRAFT
IS A WHOLE BUNCH OF PLACES THAT
WE THINK SHOULD BE CLASSIFIED AS
GAP ONE AND TWO. FOR ONE REASON
OR ANOTHER ARE NOT FOUND ON OUR
MAPS. MOST NOTABLY ARE PLACES
LIKE CONSERVATION EASEMENTS
WERE- PRIVATE LANDOWNERS HAVE
PUT THEIR LAND UNDER EASEMENT
FOR THE PURPOSES OF CONSERVATION
I'M THINKING ABOUT GRAZING LANDS
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY. THAT ARE
REALLY IMPORTANT CONTRIBUTORS TO
PROTECTING OUR VERNAL POOL
ECOSYSTEMS FOR EXAMPLE. THOSE
DON'T SHOW UP ON OUR MAPS ONE
REASON OR ANOTHER MY GUESS IS.
THAT EASEMENTS ARE ON PAPER AND
THEY'RE IN SOMEBODY'S FILE
DRAWER SO WE'RE ACTUALLY USING
THIS PROCESS TO- GET THOSE
PLACES ON OUR MAPS. I NEED TO GO
BACK AND LOOK AT YOUR SOMEBODY
BECAUSE I WAS PRETTY SURE THAT
SHOULD HAVE BEEN THERE SO IF YOU
SOMEBODY. IT'S THAT I DIDN'T
KNOW SO I'LL BE HAPPY TO TAKE A
LOOK AND FIGURE THAT OUT BUT IT
SHOULD BE IT SHOULD BE INCLUDED.
YEAH I WOULD JUST FOR THE
COMMITTEE. WHAT WE'RE HEARING
WHAT WE'RE SAYING IS TWENTY
FOUR- MILLION ACRES ROUGHLY R.
24% OF. ITS WHAT'S THE PROJECTED
WE WANT TO GET THE THIRTY AND SO
GIVEN THAT SAID IT'S JUST.
IRONIC THAT A NUMBER OF THINGS
THAT WE'VE ALREADY TAKEN INTO
ACCOUNT AND PRESERVE SUCH AS
EASEMENTS SUCH AS WHEN HIS NAP
PROGRAMS. NOW YOU HAVE MULTIPLE
KINDS OF DIFFERENT EASEMENT
PLATFORMS BUT THOSE ARE BEING
COUNTED. AND WHEN I'M JUST
SITTING TELLING YOU IS WE WORK.
THAT NUMBER. BY A 100% OF WHAT
THEIR PROJECTING AND WHAT THEY'D
LIKE TO ACHIEVE. I'M JUST
CURIOUS ABOUT THE INFORMATION
WE'RE RECEIVING. AND THE
GENUINENESS NOT THE JUST BAJOR
BURIED YOU OR ANYONE THAT'S
WORKED HARD AT THIS. PETER FACT
THAT YOU CAN JUST GOOGLE AND YOU
CAN LOOK UP RIGHT NOW. AND I
THINK IT'S UNFAIR OF US TO NOT
TAKE THOSE THINGS INTO
CONSIDERATION ESPECIALLY SINCE
THE BIO DIVERSITY IS AN
IMPORTANT THING. AND WE FORGET
THOSE COASTAL AREAS THAT ARE
ACTUALLY UNDER WATER THAT ARE
PROTECTED AS WELL NOT CALCULATED
OR FORMULATED INTO THE
PRESENTATION. IT'S REALLY HARD
FOR US FOR SOMEONE WHO'S TRYING
TO UNDERSTAND ALL OF THIS. SO I
APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU
MEDICARE I KNOW MISS GARCIA HAD
ANOTHER QUESTION. THE AD THEY
GIVE US REGULAR MISTER BENNETT'S
NEXT AND THEN WE'LL GO TO ASK
OUR THOUGHT HE- YES WITH IT JUST
STIMULATE. A LITTLE BIT OF
RESPONSIBLE I BELIEVE THAT ALL
THE RIPARIAN SANCTUARY AREAS ARE
INCLUDED AND I. AT AND CAN WE
GET A CONFIRMATION OF THE RAIN
CHECK SURE AREAS INCLUDED. IN
THE THIRTY BY THIRTY I BELIEVE
THEY ARE. WELL MASKING NOW THE-
GOLF. HE YEAH SO ON I THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENEFIT QUESTION
ON. THEY ARE NOT AND HERE'S WHY
AND THIS GETS TO THE THIS GETS
TO THE DISCUSSION- IT'S JUST A
CARD WHICH IS CURRENTLY A
NATIONAL SANCTUARIES ONE MAJOR
THING THAT THEY ALL HAVE IN
COMMON I'M A CONSERVATION
PERSPECTIVE IS THAT YOU CAN'T DO
OIL AND GAS EXTRACTION AND YOU
CAN'T DO. ON EXTRACTION AND ALSO
SEABED MINING THOSE SORTS OF
THINGS BONTA THAT'S A REALLY BIG
DEAL I DON'T MEAN A DISCOUNT
THAT IN ANY WAY SHAPE OR FORM.
S. THE OF THIS IS THERE'S A
CONSISTENCY IN THEIR FROM THE
STANDPOINT OF. OURS ARE
POLLUTION POLLUTION PREVENTION
REQUIREMENTS IS THERE MY THEIR
FISHING REQUIREMENTS ON FOR
EXTRACTION AND ANY OF THOSE
OTHER SORTS OF THINGS. AND SO
RIGHT NOW THERE IS. A LITTLE BIT
OF A DISAGREEMENT IT'S NOT A
100% CLEAR WHAT THE FEDS ARE
DOING ON THIS BUT IT APPEARS
THAT THEY WILL COUNT THEN ASKED
ME THANKS REYES. I'M BUT FROM
THE STANDPOINT OF. BY- DIVERSE
PROTECTION IN THIS IS THIS IS
REALLY A CRITICAL PART OF THIS
DISCUSSION. IS THAT ON THERE'S
THE BANKING RIGHT NOW STAFF AND
WE BELIEVE ME THIS IS. IT HOW DO
WE GET TO THIRTY BY THIRTY NOT
GET TO THIRTY BY TOMORROW. ON
AND SO ON THIS IS THE REASON WHY
WE NEED TO WORK. WITH
COMMUNITIES WITH MULTIPLE
STAKEHOLDER GROUPS ON THE GET
THESE SORTS OF DISCUSSIONS AND
SO. ON FOR NASH MEANS
SANCTUARIES AND WE'VE ALREADY
STARTED A DISCUSSION WITH- SOME
OF THE DIRECTORS OF THE
SANCTUARIES. ON YOU KNOW THEY'RE
VERY VERY OPEN TO DISCUSSIONS ON
WHAT ELSE NEEDS TO BE DONE TO
PROTECT OUR BIODIVERSITY. SO
THAT'S WHERE I WAS GIVING
EXAMPLES STARTED JUMPING AHEAD.
ON THINGS LIKE A VESSEL'S SPEED
ONE THAT BE YOUR PROJECT I
REMEMBER ALL ON IN YOUR DISTRICT
AS YOU NOW- THERE'S BEEN A LOT
OF WELL STRIKES ON ON AND SO
THAT'S- NOT SOMETHING THAT
OBVIOUSLY WANT TO GET BETTER AT
SO THAT'S WHAT THAT'S WHAT LEVEL
OF PROTECTION THAT COULD BE.
ADDED THERE ARE WHERE THE TEND
NOT BECOMES A SPEED ON THAT
RATHER THAN NON VOLUNTARY FOR
LARGER VESSELS. ON POLLUTION
PREVENTION ON AGAIN I KNOW YOU I
KNOW YOU'RE YOU HAVE A STRONG
BACKGROUND. ON THIS FROM THE
STANDPOINT OF RUNOFF POLLUTION
WHAT CAN WE DO TO REDUCE PLASTIC
POLLUTION IN AN AREA THOSE ARE
BIODIVERSITY MEASURES THAT ARE
NOT. I HAVE NO TAKE NO CHANG I
MEAN NO FOR. THOSE SORTS OF
THINGS. AND SO ON. THAT'S AND I
LIKE THAT WE REALLY LOOK. TO
HAVE. YOU THEM AND THE MONEY AND
YEARS AHEAD. ON TO GET THEIR
SORE FEELING IS. THAT ON THE
CURRENT LEVEL OF CONSERVATION
PROVIDED BY NASA MEANS
SANCTUARIES. IS A GREAT START
BUT IT DOES NOT MEET THE
DURABILITY DEFINITION. FOR THE
BIO DIVERSITY PROTECTION.
DEFINITION ON THE DOCTOR NORRIS
LAID OUT IN THE DOCUMENT. IF I
TOOK THIS RUNNING BACK REAL
QUICK SO I THINK THERE'S ONE
THING MISSING FROM THIS
CONVERSATION THAT I WOULD JUST
LIKE. YOU TO ADDRESS WHICH IS
NOBODY HAS DEFINED TERRIBLE WE
JUST KEEP SAYING THEY HAVE TO
BE. TERRIBLY PROTECTED BUT- AS
AN ATTORNEY I'D LIKE TO KNOW
WHAT THAT MEANS. WHICH I THINK
MIGHT GET TO PART OF WHAT MR
BIGELOW IS SAYING IF THERE'S A
CONSERVATION EASEMENT FOR TWENTY
YEARS. I WOULD ASSUME THAT'S NOT
TERRIBLY PROTECTIVE- WE HAVE NO
DEFINITION AT THIS POINT. WHAT
IS IT OR IS IT WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT ARE MEANS BY TO. ACTUALLY
IT I CAN ACTUALLY NO BUT I MEAN
THE THIRTY BY THIRTY DEFINITION
MISTER GONNA YOURS NO I LIKE
ONLINE BUT IT'S NOT MINE IT'S
JUST EIGHTY CALIFORNIA'S. IT'S
AN IN PERPETUITY AGREEMENT
BETWEEN THREE PARTIES LANDOWNER
THE LOCAL AND THE STATE. ANY ONE
OF THE LOCAL. OR THE STATE CAN-
ASKED TO BREAK THAT AGREEMENT.
BUT IT'S ADORABLE AGREEMENT THAT
GOES IN PERPETUITY AND TELL
SOMETHING IS BROKEN AND IT HAS
TO TAKE THE ORIGINAL LANDOWNERS.
AND THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT THE
STATE THEN FOLLOWS UP WITH IT IT
CAN. IN MOST CASES AGREED TO
DOING AWAY WITH THAT AGREEMENT
BUT IN MOST CASES IT WON'T RIGHT
SO WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY'RE
HOW THEY'RE DEFINING UNDER
THIRTY OR THIRTY DURABLE SO
THAT. SO I DON'T KNOW IF THAT IS
DURABLE BY THE RECOGNITION SO
DOCTORS DO YOU MIND ADDRESSING
THIS QUESTION. AND I SURE OF
WHAT HAPPENED TO- SO IN THE
DOCUMENT DO LIVE WHAT WE MEAN BY
DURABLE I THINK THEY'RE THEY'RE
STILL GREAT CONVERSATIONS ABOUT-
SUPER WILLIAMS ACTORS TWENTY
YEARS ENOUGH WE LEAVE ROOM FOR
THAT BUT BUT FUNDAMENTALLY WE
TALK ABOUT- LANDS THAT ARE IN
PUBLIC OWNERSHIP FOR YOU KNOW
PERMANENTLY IN PUBLIC OWNERSHIP
FOR BIODIVERSITY PURPOSE THAT'S
ADORABLY PROTECTED AREA-
CONSERVATION EASEMENTS AS WAS
DESCRIBED SO DURABLE- AGREEMENTS
BETWEEN THREE PARTIES TO PROTECT
- AS WELL AS- AND THIS IS A
SOMEWHAT. CATEGORY BUT
ADMINISTRATIVELY PROTECTED AREAS
THAT HAVE GONE THROUGH A FORMAL
RULE MAKING SO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT OFTEN WILL DO A
RULEMAKING TRIED SOMETHING A
ROADLESS AREA THAT TAKES YEARS
OF ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURE WE
THINK THAT COUNTS AS A DURABLE
PROTECTION OBVIOUSLY IF THAT IS
ON DONE THAT NOT CHANGES- OUR
OUR CALCULATION BUT- THOSE ARE
THE SORT OF THREE CATEGORIES
RECEIVED FOR FALLING INTO DURHAM. THANK YOU ARE. THAT OKAY RAND
HAD MEDICAL. THANK YOU SO I
BELIEVE IT DIDN'T IN- IN
RESPONSE TO THE COMMENTS AT
WHILE THEY'RE LOTS OF AREA THAT
IS IDENTIFIED AS OPEN SPACE WHAT
YOU WERE TRYING TO DO IS TO HAVE
THAT AREA PEOPLE OPEN SPACE AND
ALL OF THESE OTHER DEFINITIONS
THAT ARE OUT THERE. TO TRY TO
MAKE SURE THAT IT MEETS THE
CRITERIA THAT FALL WITH WOULD
FALL UNDER THIRTY BY THIRTY AND
SO I THINK IT'S A IT'S
LEGITIMATE TO ISSUE IS SIMPLY
CLARIFYING OUR DEFINITIONS AS AS
YOU AS YOU MENTIONED AND THEN
FOR ALL OF US TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
WE MEAN WHEN WE SAY THIRTY BY
THREE. SO TO SAY WERE DONE OR
NOT DONE BASED ON HOW MUCH LAND
IS OUT THERE WERE WORK WE'RE NOT
DONE UNTIL WE CLARIFY OUR
DEFINITIONS AND WHEN WE DO THAT
AS AS FOR THIS TALKED ABOUT THAT
I THINK THAT'S THE EFFORT THAT
IS OUT THERE WHAT. YOU KNOW I
CERTAINLY HAVE LOTS OF WHICH
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF NATIONAL-
FOREST LAND SOME OF THAT LAND IS
BEING HEAVILY AND THEY WERE
GONNA DO MINING ON A TECH CENTER
I'M NOT THAT MUCH I DON'T THINK
PEOPLE WOULD SAY HEY WE'RE GONNA
COUNT THAT LAND AND SO. OF THE
THAT'S THE DISTINCTION BUT THE
OTHER QUESTION THAT I HAVE IS-
EVAN DERANGED ACTUARY IS- AND
THE MARINE PROTECTED AREAS ARE.
HUGE IT OFF THE COAST OF-
VENTURA COUNTY- IN PARTICULAR
AND THERE WAS A REFERENCE MADE
BY ONE THE SPEAKERS THAT THEY
THAT THAT. THAT THAT NATIONAL
MARINE SANCTUARY AREAS
REPRESENTED 40% OF THE LAND AND
I DIDN'T CATCH 40% OF WHAT OF
WHAT LANDS SO COULD SOME OF THE
WATERS UP. OF ALL THE CURRICULA
CAL. IS 4% OVER THE ANTS ANTS IN
STATE WATERS IT'S ACTUAL. ON
WELL OVER FORTY PERCENT- IT'S
INTERNATIONAL ME THANKS VERY. SO
OF ALL OF THE OF THE FOR THE
WHOLE COAST OF CALIFORNIA
PERCENT OF THE STATE WATER HIS
NATIONAL MARINE SANCTUARY. THAT
IS CORRECT CORRECT AND THEN WE
HAVE- WE HAVE NO FISHING- MARINE
SANCTUARIES OFF THE COAST OF THE
CHANNEL ISLANDS. DOES VISIT IF
YOU'RE OVER THERE'S NO TAKE IT
ALL TREMENDOUS RIVERS TREMENDOUS
OPPOSITION WHEN THEY WERE
CREATED AND NOW THERE'S
TREMENDOUS BIODIVERSITY COMING
OUT OF THOSE HOW ARE THEY BEING
TREATED. SO THAT SERVICE SO WE
HAVE SOME WEIRD OVERLAPS HERE-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENNETT AND THAT
IS. A GREAT EXAMPLE WOULD BE THE
NORTHERN CHANNEL ISLANDS WHERE
YOU HAVE- A- AND NOW THANKS. BUT
YOU ALSO HAVE THIS PART OF THE
STATE PROGRAM. MARINE PROTECTED
AREAS AND SO WE HAVE MARINE
PROTECTED AREAS WHICH HAVE AN
ADDITIONAL LEVEL OF PROTECTION
THAT THAT'S WHERE YOU ACTUALLY
HAVE. ON EITHER NO TAKE MPAS ARE
LIMITED TAKE CAMP YES- I'M
CONSERVATION BASED ON PS ON THAT
ARE WITH EMBEDDED WITH NATIONAL
MARINE SANCTUARIES AND SO WE'RE
SAYING. UNEQUIVOCALLY AND
BELIEVE ME THERE'S PEOPLE WHO
AGREE WITH US MOST PEOPLE
DISAGREE WITH PASSED SOME LOT OF
PEOPLE IN MY NOW COMMUNITY ONLY
ONE ACCOUNT THE 9% NOT ALL
SIXTEEN PERCENT. BY THAT SIXTEEN
PERCENT OF WATERS IS. A STATE
MARINE PROTECTED AREA AND SO
WE'RE SAYING OKAY THAT'S OUR
BASELINE THAT'S WHERE WE'RE
STARTING. ON AND SO A LOT OF
THOSE MPAS ARE ARE EMBEDDED
WITHIN THE NOW MEANS. WHAT WERE
. WHAT WE WILL TO START. WITH
THIS PATHWAY PER. IS DISCUSS ON
. IT WHAT INTENTIONAL WOULD YOU
NEED TO DEAL WITH AND THEN AFTER
MEANS SANCTUARIES PROVIDE A
LEVEL OF CONSERVATION THAT MEETS
IS WE JUST HAD THIS DISCUSSION
ON THE DEFINITIONS. ON AND
ACTUALLY MEET THE SPIRIT OF THE
DEFINITION BOTH UNDER ABILITY IN
BIODIVERSITY PROTECTION SO
THAT'S- RIGHT THAT'S THE
DISTINCTION ON THERE IS THAT IT
IS MAY I AM CANCER BATTED WITH
SANCTUARY. RIGHT NOW ALL OF THE
MARINE PROTECTED AREAS ARE.
INCLUDED CORRECT. OKAY YEAH
RIGHT THANK THERE'S THIS ON THE
PUBLIC WAY THERE'S A LOT OF FOR
THAT THAT'S SO STAY IN OUR A
POSITION AS A RIGHT NOW AND I
JUST WANNA GARNER IN TERMS OF
HOW BOUT THEY HAVE BEEN FOR THE
FISHING ACTUALLY OF BECAUSE OF
THE- THE AMOUNT OF BIODIVERSITY
IN AND THE AMOUNT OF FISH
POPULATION THAT'S COMING OUT OF
THOSE MARINE PROTECTED AREAS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
MISS GARCIA. PAT THANK YOU I DR
NORRIS LET ME TAKE A SO A LITTLE
BIT FROM THE MARINE FIGHTER AND-
THE NATIONAL FOREST AND GREAT
PARKS LIKE YOSEMITE TO LIMPING A
PICTURE. OF HIS IN YOUR
PRESENTATION IN THE DISCUSSION
SO FAR I DON'T I DON'T HAVE
CLARITY FOR URBAN AREAS LIKE I
LIVE IN A HAVE CONSTITUENCIES
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THAT WANT
TO BE PART OF THIS THIRTY BY
THIRTY DISCUSSION AND HAVE BEEN
ASKING QUESTIONS. AND HAVE BEEN
TRYING TO GET CREATIVE BUT WE'VE
BEEN HITTING WALLS- BUT I LIVE
IN A VERY LANDLOCKED- URBAN VERY
DENSE WANTED THAT. OF THE- IN
STATE ACTUALLY OUT THERE AND- IT
NOT CLEAR HOW WE PARTICIPATE ARE
HOW WE HELP GET TO THAT SIX
MILLION ACRE ALSO VERY PARK POOR
- COMMUNITY. AND I'LL GIVE YOU
AN EXAMPLE I HAVE. THE GREEN WAY
IT'S A WAY THAT'S RIGHT OUTSIDE
OF MY DISTRICT- THREE SOME WITH
YOUR AND TOWARDS ORANGE COUNTY
AND IT'S BEEN A GREAT INVESTMENT
FOR THAT COMMUNITY. AND IF YOU
CROSS THE BRIDGE ON THE RIVER TO
THEIR SIDE THERE'S- OF INTERCOM
- AND SET BECAUSE- I LIVE WITH
WOULD LOVE TO SEE THAT GREEN WE
CONNECTED THAT CONCRETE AND HAD
WE TREAT THAT TO BE A MORE OPEN.
GREEN OPEN SPACES I SEE A RIVER
THAT'S BEEN. POURED OVER WITH
CONCRETE. ALONG THE WAY ABOVE WE
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO GET ANSWERS
ABOUT HOW WE DO THAT WE HAVE A
PIECE OF LAND THAT WE THINK WE
COULD ACQUIRE. ART AND THAT WE
THINK WOULD BE THAT PERFECT
CONNECTOR BUT IT'S NOT CLEAR
THAT WE QUALIFIER WE CAN. TAKE
OVER A BE PART OF THIS THIRTY BY
THIRTY WHEN WE THINK OF THIRTY
BY THIRTY WE THINK OF THAT AND
THAT. THAT CREATIVE THERE CAN
YOU A LITTLE BIT ABOUT FROM
DISCUSSIONS YOU HAD FROM DEATH
AND- HOW AND IN SPACE CAN TO
THIS SIX MILLION ACRE THAT YOU
HAVE. THANK YOU SOME. FOR THAT
QUESTION THAT'S SUCH IMPORTANT.
OF WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT- FOR
SMALLER SAY THAT THE CAR. WE'VE
HAD AROUND STATE IT'S BEEN
REMARKABLE HOW MANY PLACES HAVE
BEEN IDENTIFIED AS OPPORTUNITIES
TO. HELP US MEET THE GOALS I'M
THINK SPUR. IN URBAN AREAS.
LARGE ACRE BROWNFIELD COULD BE
RESTORED AND TURNED INTO-
THRIVING BIODIVERSITY AREAS THAT
ALSO PROVIDE ACCESS AND I'VE
SEEN THAT THROUGHOUT THE STATE
SO THAT'S VERY EXCITING- BUT
ALSO I WANT TO REMIND. EVERYONE
THAT YOU KNOW THIRTY BY THIRTY
IS DEFINITELY NOT. ALL
CONSERVATION IN CALIFORNIA NOR
IS IT INTENDED TO MEET ALL OF
OUR- OUTDOOR ACCESS PRIORITIES
WHICH IS WHY THE ADMINISTRATION.
HAS LAUNCHED THE OUTDOORS FOR
ALL INITIATIVE SO WITHIN
CALIFORNIA NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY WE ARE EMBARKING ON A
YEAR LONG CONVERSATION. ON HOW
TO ENSURE THERE IS ACCESS FOR
ALL TO PUT AN END IN OUTDOOR
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL YOU KNOW AS
AS THE COVERED CRISIS IDENTIFIED
FOR US SO MANY CALIFORNIANS HAD
NO ACCESS TO GREEN SPACE. THAT'S
AN ISSUE WE WANT TO REMEDY AND
SO THE OUTER FOR ALL INITIATIVES
DESIGNED INTENTIONALLY TO MAKE
SURE THAT COMMUNITIES HAVE
PARKS. AND HAVE OPPORTUNITIES TO
GET OUTSIDE AND ENJOY GREEN
SPACES SO THOSE THESE TWO PIECES
GO TOGETHER. THEY'RE NOT THEY'RE
NOT MUTUALLY EXCLUSIVE THERE ARE
PLACES WHERE CAN REALLY DO REAL
IN. REST I'M I'M LOOKING AT.
ABOUT COASTAL WETLANDS AND ALL
THE OPPORTUNITIES THERE TO
PROMOTE CLIMATE RESILIENCE GIVE
PEOPLE ACCESS TO THE COAST AND
ALSO- PROVIDE FOR OUR
BIODIVERSITY MANY OF THOSE ARE
CLOSE TO URBAN AREAS. SO WE SEE
ALL THESE LITTLE PIECES FITTING
TOGETHER BUT THEY DON'T ALL-
THEY'RE ALL COMPLETELY OVERLAP
IT'S A IT'S A VENN DIAGRAM.
KICKED SOMETHING DOCTOR THERE
PLEASE. ON THE- YOU KNOW NO.
KNOW YOUR THIS I THINK INCLUDED
SO GABRIEL WATERS. IN AND JOHN.
YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY AND NORMA
STAFFORD'S ON AN NECKLACE AT-
OVER THE DECK. I'M AYE AYE THIS
ISSUE AND IN THIS IS AN ERROR
THAT- DOCTOR NINTH ABOUT A LOT
IS THAT. YOU KNOW THAT URBAN
PARKS AND CONNECTIVITY ON TO THE
WILD LANDS ON I THINK IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE DEFINITELY.
EXCITED TO TALK ABOUT MOVING
FORWARD ON IN IN THAT REALIZING
THAT ON IT OF THAT CONNECTIVITY
ON RIVER RESTORATION AND
WETLANDS ALONGSIDE THE RIVER AND
AN OPEN SPACE ALONGSIDE THE
RIVER BUT ALSO MORE INTERNALLY.
IF THERE'S DEMONSTRATE. BOMB
WHILE I CORD OR CAN. ON IT AND
THERE'S SOME PERMANENT TO IT ON
AND IT'S A LARGE ENOUGH SIZE
THAT'S OF BIODIVERSITY BENEFIT I
MEAN WE SHOULD WE ARE ABSOLUTELY
GOING TO BE HAVING THIS
CONVERSATIONS IT'S JUST. LOS
ANGELES IN PARTICULAR IS SUCH A
UNIQUE SITUATION BECAUSE THE
INCREDIBLE BIODIVERSITY THERE
SAN DIEGO ITSELF FALLS INTO THIS
CATEGORY AS WELL BOND AND BEING
ABLE TO HAVE THOSE DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT. ON IT YOU KNOW BECAUSE
THE NEXUS BETWEEN DOUBTS AS AS
DR NORTH OF PRODUCT I IT'S I
THINK THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT.
IN FOR SO I WITH ARE ALL PART OF
THERE SO I COULD FOLLOW UP TO
THE AND I'M TALKING ABOUT IS
ACTUALLY NEXT TO THIS AND GAVE
OVER A BED- AND I'LL I I'M WHICH
BETWEEN THE SINGER WILL IN THE
L. A. RIVER BETH TO CONCRETE MY
- THAT USED TO BE REVERSED. BOSS
LET ME LET ME SAY THAT EVERY
TIME WE USE THE WORD RIVER YOU
GET TO CONCRETE MONSTERS OF EVER
ANYMORE AND IF THERE'S WATER TO
THE IT'S BEEN THIS TRIED AND
SEWER SYSTEMS MY AREA- BUT THAT
IS OUR BIODIVERSITY AND WE NEED
TO GO BACK TO RESTORING THE
SPACES AND WE THINK ABOUT THIRTY
BY THIRTY. THOSE ARE THE SPACES
THAT WE LIVE WITH AND WHEN YOU
SAY ABOUT A LOT OF SPACE WHAT IS
THAT MARGIN OF SPACE BECAUSE I
FEEL LIKE THAT'S NOT REALISTIC
IN ONE OF THE DENSEST. AREAS OF
CALIFORNIA LET YOU KNOW SPACE
MIGHT ONLY BE A HALF AN ACRE. I
AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT MANY
MANY A OR AS WELL MANY MANY
ACRES. THAT WAY THAT'S COUNTRY.
AND SO YOU KNOW IT'S ONE TALK
ABOUT THESE. THAT ARE REALLY A
AND I CAN SERVICE TO EXCITED
ABOUT IT THE TRANSFER OUT HOW TO
A PART OF IT WE GET TOLD ALEXI
NOT MAYBE MAYBE LATER ON WITH
THIS OTHER PROJECT IT'S ALWAYS
LATER ON AND NEVER TRICKLE SAID.
AND THAT'S WHEN THE FEELING LIKE
THIS IS TRUE DOWN ENVIRONMENT-
WHICH HAS BY THE COUNTIES ON
PURPOSE AND SO I HAVE A LACK OF
IMPATIENCE IT'S BEEN ALL MY
LIFE- AND I LITERALLY HAVE TO
MAKE THE CHOICE OF DO I QUITE ON
THE RIVER BUT THAT'S ACTUALLY
PARALLEL TO THE FREEWAY THAT
MOVES ALL THE GETS MOMENTS FROM
THE PORT TO THE REALLY GREAT. MY
DISTRICT AND HOW HEALTHY IS THAT
LITTLE TREE BUFFER SOME WEIGHT
MIGHT BE YOU KNOW APPRECIATED AS
WELL. AND SO THAT'S THAT'S WHERE
MY FRUSTRATIONS COMING I'M VERY
EXCITED ABOUT THIS PROGRAM BUT-
THE SIMPLE FIGURE IT OUT OR
SOMETHING DIFFERENT DOESN'T
ALWAYS SEEM TO CATCH UP IN MY
COMMUNITY. MR ALL RANDOM MESSAGE
. THANK YOU A MANAGER I'M VERY
GRATEFUL THAT MEMBER GARCIA FOR
REFER RAISING AN ISSUE THAT
REALLY EVEN IN THE ORIGINAL
THIRTY THIRTIES ARE AS AS I
WROTE IT THERE WAS A DUAL
PURPOSE ONE IS TO PROTECT PLAN
WHAT ARE THE OTHER ONE WAS
ACCESS AND AN EQUITY AS WELL-
AND I HAVE MY BILL THIS YEAR AB
THIRTY- WHICH FOCUSES ON-
ENVIRONMENT IT THE OUTDOOR. TO
NATURE AND I THINK IT REALLY
BLENDS WELL WITH THE COMMENTS
THAT COULD THAT- ASSEMBLY GARCIA
. TENSION IN THAT THERE ARE ALL
THESE LAW PRIDE IN AREAS BECAUSE
BUT THERE ARE PLENTY OF
OPPORTUNITIES AND- COMMUNITIES
LIKE MINE AND CERTAINLY IN
SUMMER GARCIA'S WERE B. THAT
WEATHER IS OPPORTUNITY. TO
CREATE SPACES AND TO CREATE- IN
ABOUT TO CREATE. FOR ACCESS- TO
OPEN SPACE- AND SO YOU KNOW I
THINK THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WE-
ISN'T NECESSARILY SOMETHING THAT
WE NEED TO WAIT ON IF I HAVE
ANOTHER BILL PUT UP FOR POCKET
FOURS. YOUR NEED THIRTY FEET BY
THIRTY FEET TO CREATE A PROBLEM
FOR US WAS EXTREMELY- BENEFITS
FOR BIODIVERSITY INCREASING
GREEN SPACES. AS WELL- AS I JUST
WANT TO MAKE THAT AS A AS A
GENERAL COMMENT THAT THAT- IS
NOT A NICE TO HAVE IT'S A MUST
HAVE THAT WE CREATE ACCESS AND
CREATE. EQUITY IN TERMS OF OUR
PROGRAMS CREATING- OF THAT
MEETING THESE GOALS OPEN SPACE
AND WATER- PROTECTING OUR WATER
AS WELL- IN A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS IS ONE EIGHT ONE IS
REGARDING FUNDING I'M ALSO IS.
GRATEFUL FOR THE- MILLION DOLLAR
SUPPORT TRAVEL ENTITIES OF
THINGS WOULD BE CRITICAL THOSE
PARTNERSHIPS IF YOU WANT TO MEET
THESE GOALS IN A MEANINGFUL
MANNER- AND- A QUESTION
REGARDING I GUESS WHAT OTHER
MEANINGFUL WAYS IS IT
ADMINISTRATION. OFFERING TO
OTHER KIND OF COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS TO MEET SOME OF
THESE GOALS AND THE LARGER ISSUE
OF- JUST. IN GENERAL IN ORDER TO
PROVIDE FOR ACQUISITION
RESTORATION MANAGEMENT SO IT'S
GONNA BE A LOT OF MONEY AS
OPPOSED TO ADMINISTRATION PLAN.
PROVIDED FUNDING OVER THE LONG
TERM IN WORKING OBVIOUSLY BUT.
THE LEGISLATURE. WELL THE A
THAT'S A I'M NOT. FULLY READY TO
ANSWER I WILL SAY YOU KNOW IT'S
CLEAR IN OUR DOCUMENT THAT WE
RECOGNIZE THAT IT'S NOT ALL OF
THE FUNDING IS GOING TO COME
FROM THE STATE RIGHT SOME OF
THIS IS WORKING IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. AND
AS  POINTED OUT- WHEN I WENT
THROUGH THEPATHWAYS. THERE'S
ACTUALLY A LOT OF CONSERVATION
THAT'S HAPPENING NOW FROM. TO
YOUR PROJECTS AND EVEN SMALL
PROJECTS THAT ISN'T BEING DONE
IN A STRATEGIC WAY SO WE CAN
ACTUALLY LEVERAGE EXISTING MONEY
AND USE IT TO SUPPORT THIRTY BY
THIRTY MORE EFFECTIVELY. SO I
THINK THERE'S A SUITE OF
APPROACHES THAT ARE GOING TO GET
US THERE- BUT OBVIOUSLY. IT'S A
LONG TERM COMMITMENT AND I'M NOT
YOU KNOW YOU ASKED A BIT ABOUT
WORKING WITH COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS AND WHAT THE
MINISTRATIONS DOING I MEAN WE
THINK THAT'S THAT'S CENTRAL TO-
MAKING THIS WORK. AND PART OF
WHAT YOU'LL SEE AS WE ROLL OUT
OUR PROPOSAL- FOR THAT NATURE
BASED SOLUTIONS SET ASIDE. BUT
YOU KNOW THE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS FOR TRIBES WE THOUGHT
WAS A REALLY SIGNIFICANT DOWN
PAYMENT IN THAT DIRECTION. YEAH
I AGREE I THINK THAT THERE'S-
THE PARTNERSHIP ASPECT IS GOING
TO HAPPEN COME WITH RESOURCES.
THAT HELP TO LEVERAGE THE- STATE
FUNDS WHETHER IT'S LIKE YOU BE
IN OUR AREA THEY OPEN. OR OR
THERE ARE TRUSTS THAT. WITH WITH
. PARTNERSHIP CAN REALLY GET A
LOT OF BANG FOR THEIR BUCK AS
WELL AS- TAKING BAGS OF THE
STATE RESOURCES. AND THE- THE
LAST QUESTION I HAVE. IS
REGARDING IMPLEMENTATION OF
THIRTY THIRTY. OF OVER THE NEXT
EIGHT YEARS AND- HOW WE ENSURE
THAT FUTURE GOVERNMENTS WILL
CONTINUE THESE EFFORTS- NOT ONLY
FOR THE NEXT EIGHT YEARS UNTIL
THEY'RE TWENTY THIRTY AND BEYOND. YOU KNOW I I'M I'M HOPEFUL
THAT WE- THE FOUNDATION OF THE
DISEASE ACROSS CALIFORNIA THAT
THEY'RE NOT GONNA LET THIS DROP
I MEAN THE AMOUNT OF. EXCITEMENT
THAT I SEE TALKING TO PEOPLE
AROUND THE STATE AND YOU KNOW
THERE BUT THERE'S BEEN SOME
POLLING THAT 70% OF CALIFORNIANS
THINK THAT MORE CONSERVATION IS
A GREAT IDEA. AND ARE EXCITED TO
SEE THIRTY BY THIRTY CONTINUES-
I'M HOPEFUL THIS MOVEMENT HAS
POWER WEBI- ME CERTAIN. THOUGHT
I HOPE SO AS WELL AND I COMMEND
YOU ON THE GO THE MINISTRATION
FROM REALLY MAKING THIS A
PRIORITY. WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE OR IN DOING THAT-
YOU KNOW I HAVE OTHER
LEGISLATION REGARDING CODIFYING
SOME OF THESE GOALS BECAUSE I
THINK ULTIMATELY. YOU JUST CAN'T
MISS WE COUNT ON THE FACT THE
NEXT GOVERNOR IS GOING TO BE. I
HAVE THE SAME MINDSET OF
GOVERNORS ADAM PRIORITIES AND
THAT'S FINE BUT I THINK IT'S A-
THINK WE'RE- WE SHOWN A- WITH
THE GUY. WITHIN AS OF THIS I
THINK VERY PRODUCTIVE THAT I
THINK WE SHOULD. TAKE THE STEPS
TO MAKE IT STAND THE TEST OF
TIME SO TO SPEAK THANK YOU THANK
YOU MANAGER. THANK YOU MISTER
KALRA MISTER MERRETT SAID SHE
RESPECTS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
IF I CAN DIRECTOR CALL. TO THE
GOLD. MR GOLD. OUR OUR YOU
FAMILIAR THE REDONDO COSTA WELL. ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT THE AT
THE POWER PLANT YES. YES I AM
FAMILIAR OKAY- SO. IF THE
COMMUNITY WANTED TO ABOUT.
TRYING TO HAVE. THAT A LAND
DESIGNATED AS PART OF YOUR
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE COASTAL
WETLAND RESTORATION EFFORT
HATTON HOW DO WE THAT. I THINK I
HAVE THAT MEETING WITH A BUNCH
OF PEOPLE NEXT NEXT WEEK IF I'M
NOT MISTAKEN I'M IT'S CALM BY
EIGHTY KNOW I KNOW HAS BEEN
DIFFICULT OKAY. LEVEL ON AS WELL
ON AND- IT SO I WOULD BACK WITH
A BETTER ANSWER TO YOU. AFTER
THAT MEETING- BUT IF IT INCLUDES
MEETING WITH THE MAYOR FIVE I
THINK BRAND STILL AMERICA WE
BEACH AND OTHERS OF THAT ON BUT
IT'S- ON DEFINITELY CAUGHT THE
ATTENTION OF THE ADMINISTRATION
AND THEY'RE IN THEY'RE MEETING
SCHEDULED- FOR FURTHER.
DISCUSSION MARK. I THANK YOU BUT
BUT- THAT'S A NEW. OF THE OF THE
OF CULTURE THAT WOULD FIT INTO.
THE THIRTY BY THIRTY INITIATIVE
. YEAH CONCEPTUALLY CONCEPTUALLY
YES ON IT SO IT TO BE A
CANDIDATE IT'S A LITTLE SMALL SO
IT DEPENDS HOW LARGE THE WETLAND
CREATION AND RESTORATION IS. ON
IF YOU LOOK AT IT YOU KNOW AND
J. SOMEWHAT WHEN BUT- HAVE NOT
BEEN WORST LIKE LOST THREE. AND
BY ALL AYE AND- YOU KNOW OUR MOM
BEACH IN VENTURA- THERE'S A LOT
MORE- BIODIVERSITY. ON AT THOSE
BUT THAT DOES MEAN ON AS I IF I
CAN'T ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA
MADE A VERY POWERFUL POINT ON
THAT SMALLER PROJECTS. AREN'T
IMPORTANT TO. THIS FARMER
COMPONENT NEED TO BE FOR SHORT.
OKAY YOU- I A QUESTION I'M NOT
OF FOR DOCTOR GOLDER DOC NORRIS
- BUT- ANOTHER- EXAMPLE MY
DISTRICT THE PALACE VERDES- OPEN
SPACE- I IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT THAT IS OWNED BY THE CITY
RANCHO PALLETS FOR DAYS BUT THAT
ALSO BE AN EXAMPLE OF A
CANDIDATE FOR THE THIRTY BY
THIRTY INITIAL. I PLEADING AND
NOT KNOWING THE LEVEL OF
PROTECTION I THINK I THINK THAT
REALLY IS THE POINT OF IT IF
IT'S AN OPEN SPACE THAT IS BEING
MANAGED FOR CONSERVATION
PURPOSES AND- THE DEFINITION.
I'M ASSUMING DR NOR. AND I WOULD
THAT THAT WOULD COUNT JUST DON'T
KNOW ENOUGH ABOUT. HOW HOW IT'S
BEING MANAGED AT THIS POINT ON
IT IN THAT MANNER. AND IN TERMS
OF THE DISCUSSION EARLIER ABOUT
THE IMPORTANCE OF- THE THEIR
REGIONAL PARTNERS THE REGIONAL
COALITIONS- WHO WHO WHO ARE THE
- WHO IS- THE REGIONAL COALITION
THAT- THAT I NEED TO REACH OUT
TO- AND THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
AREA. I SO I'M GONNA TRY TO JUMP
IN HERE THROUGH THE COURSE OF
OUR ENTIRE ENGAGEMENT THERE WERE
THERE WERE REGIONAL COALITIONS
THAT SORT OF SPRING UP TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIRTY BY THIRTY
AND SENT IN LETTERS I COULD GO
BACK AND LOOK AND SEE WHO THOSE
PARTICULAR PEOPLE WORK- BUT AT
THE SAME TIME. I'M TALKING MORE
BROADLY LIKE THERE'S THOSE KINDS
OF GROUPS THAT GATHER TOGETHER
AND SAID WE WANT TO BE PART OF
THIRTY BY THIRTY AS WELL AS YOU
KNOW BY WHAT WAS PREVIOUSLY
MENTIONED YOU KNOW LIKE THAT SAN
DIEGO MULTI SPECIES CONSERVATION
PLANNING GROUPS OF THAT SORT SO.
IT REALLY CAN BE ANY ANY ONE OF
THOSE AT. MY I MIGHT TAKE A
MOMENT JUST TO- TO DO A LITTLE
MORE. ABOUT OF THIS WHAT COUNTS
AND DOESN'T. THERE'S NOT SOME
YOU KNOW. YOU KNOW MARK HOLDEN
AYE I JOKE SOMETIMES I'M NOT
SITTING THERE WITH A CLIPBOARD
ON WHICH PROJECTS ARE IN IN
WHICH PROJECTS ARE OUT WE'RE
REALLY INTERESTED IN USING
EXISTING PROGRAMS OF EXISTING.
APPROACHES TO GETTING THIS
CONSERVE DONE SO ALL THE THINGS
THAT ARE TRIED AND TRUE THAT WE
ALREADY KNOW ABOUT- WHETHER
IT'S- PROTECTING AREAS THAT HAVE
ALREADY BEEN IDENTIFIED THROUGH
. HABITAT CONSERVE PLAN
ESTABLISHING A REFUGE PUTTING
INTO CONSERVATION EASEMENT ON
FOR YOU KNOW. CONSERVATION WE
WANT TO USE THE EXISTING
PROPHECIES THAT HAVE THEIR OWN
CRITERIA AND THEIR OWN
APPROACHES HOW TO GET THIS WORK
DONE SO THEY'RE NOT SORT OF A
SEPARATE. A LEDGER THAT WE USE
TO EVALUATE THESE PROJECTS WE
WANT TO. WE WANT TO USE THE
THINGS THAT WE ALL ALREADY KNOW
AND UNDERSTAND. I RIGHT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER. THANK THE
DOLLAR DID YOU YEAH. FIFTY SO
THANK YOU BOTH FOR YOUR SAY- I
READ A VERY VERY DIFFERENT-
GEOGRAPHIC AREA THAN MOST OF THE
MEMBERS TO ME BIGELOW AND I HAVE
SIMILAR- WE'RE ALSO FARMERS SO
WE HAVE WIDE OPEN SPACE THAT WE
WILL NEVER BUILD ON THERE'S NO
INTENT SO I GET THE FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE COMING FROM MY
CONSTITUENTS AND THE OPEN LANDS
ALREADY EXISTS THERE. SO YOUR
TIME OUT WORKING WITH EXISTING
PROGRAM SO WITH THE INTENT TO
INCLUDE A PROGRAM LIKE THE
WILLIAMSON ACT BE INCLUDED AND A
FOLLOW UP QUICK YOU ALSO SPOKE
ABOUT GRAZED AND- RANGELAND I'M
I'M WONDERING IF THAT IS ALSO
INCLUDED. YES SO AND I IS ONE
EXAMPLE YOU KNOW SOME OF THOSE
ARE SHE TERM TEN YEARS RIGHT
THIS MY UNDERSTANDING BUT I
RECENTLY LEARNED THERE'S TO
WILLIAMSON ACT BECAUSE LONGER SO
THAT'S A CONVERSATION WE'RE
HAVING WITH OUR PARTNERS THAT-
THAT YOU MISTER THOSE PROGRAMS
ABOUT SORT OF HOW DO WE- GET.
THE DURABILITY- OF THAT SORT OF
PROGRAM REGARDLESS OF WHETHER
THEY'RE PART OF THIRTY BY THIRTY
THOUGH YOU KNOW THEY'RE STILL A
REALLY IMPORTANT PRIORITY FOR
THE ADMINISTRATION AND AN
IMPORTANT PROGRAM TO CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT REGARDLESS OF THIRTY BY
THIRTY- BUT- IT WITH REGARD TO
GRAZING IN PARTICULAR YOU KNOW I
MIGHT. MIGHT CAREER EXPERIENCE
THERE ARE MANY MANY BEAUTIFUL
INCREDIBLE RANCHES IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY SPECIFICALLY I'M
THINKING OF THAT ARE UNDER
CONSERVATION EASEMENT THAT ARE
PROTECTING- VERNAL LANDSCAPES
THROUGH GRAZING. ACTIVITY
THROUGH ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
THOSE ARE A GREAT EXAMPLE OF THE
KINDS OF PLACES THAT WE WANT TO
ENCOURAGE THROUGH THIS. THROUGH
THIRTY BY THIRTY. SO DOES DO
COUNT IN MY- IN AND THEY'RE PART
OF OUR- DEFINITIONS WHETHER OR
NOT THEY SHOW UP ON THE MAP IS A
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT PROBLEM THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO SOLVE BUT- WE
THINK THERE'S YOU KNOW A COUPLE
HUNDRED THOUSAND POTENTIALLY-
EASEMENT PROPERTIES OUT THERE
THAT MAY OR MAY NOT BE IN OUR
DATABASE BUT THEY ABSOLUTELY
MEET OUR. DEFINITION SO HOW DID
THEY GET INTO THE DATA. WE HAVE
PUT OUT A CALL WE HAVE LITERALLY
HONORED BECAUSE I SAID IF YOU
WANT TO GET ON OUR MAPS LET US
KNOW AND PEOPLE ARE ACTUALLY
SENDING IN US INFORMATION SO WE
CAN ADD THEM TO THE DATA SO IT'S
HAPPENING ALREADY. OKAY SO.
PREDICTIONS WHEN. DIFFERENT
GROUPS THAT HAVE REPRESENT- OF
FOLK IN PARTICULAR INPUT OUT THE
CALL. SO THANK YOU. AT Y.
WORCESTER JUST FAITH THE MEMBERS
FOR THEIR DEEP ENGAGEMENT TODAY
ON THIS AND FOR BOTH OF YOU FOR
HERE TO PRESENT ON THIS IMPORT
TOPIC AND I WANNA COMMEND YOU
FOR GOING FURTHER THAN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT I KNOW THAT
WAS A HOT TOPIC BUT I THINK THEY
CAN- DOESN'T JUST LET THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SET THE TONE
WE DECIDE FOR OURSELVES WHAT
COUNTS AND I THINK THAT'S THE
WORK THAT'S BEING DONE BY YOU
AND YOUR- TEAM AND I WANT TO
COME YOU FOR THAT BECAUSE I
THINK THAT BIODIVERSITY IS
SOMETHING THAT FOR TOO LONG HAS
NOT BEEN AT THE- CENTER OF
CONVERSATIONS AND IT'S SO
CRITICAL. AND THE MORE WORK WE
DO THE BETTER OFF AND CALIFORNIA
WILL BE IN THE FUTURE SO. I JUST
WANNA THANK YOU FOR YOUR
INCREDIBLE WORK ON THIS- AND
THAT SORT OF. INTO MY FIRST
QUESTION WHICH IS SIX. ACRES IN
EIGHT YEARS WHICH- IS A LOT. AND
DO WE HAVE A SENSE OF HOW MANY
ACRES PER YEAR WE'VE BEEN
CONSERVING TO DATE. HOW WE'RE
GONNA. I ASSUME WE NEED TO
ACCELERATE THAT. SIGNIFICANTLY I
KNOW OBVIOUSLY THE MONEY YOU'RE
DISCUSSING WILL BE A PORTION OF
THAT BUT THIS SEEMS LIKE A LOT
OF LOCAL SIX MILLION ACRES AND-
THE NEXT. SECTION SIX. YEAH I
MEAN IT IT DOES SOUND LIKE A LOT
OF IT IS A LOT- I DON'T HAVE A
RATE PER YEAR AND I THINK IN
CALIFORNIA ARE CONSERVATION
PROBABLY GOES IN WAVES RIGHT WE
GET THESE BIG BONDS AND GRANTS
AND PUT. THE A BUNCH AND THEN IT
ECONOMY SORT OF PUT IT THE BACK
BURNER- I WILL TELL YOU THAT
THERE HAS BEEN- THROUGH THIS.
CALIFORNIA BY DIVERSITY COUNCIL-
WE ACTUALLY PUT OUT A CALL TO
ALL THE DIFFERENT AGENCIES
WITHIN THE COUNCIL AND ASK THEM
FOR THE PROGRAMS THAT THEY
ADMINISTER THAT ARE GOING TO
HELP MOVE THE NEEDLE ON THIRTY
BY THIRTY. AND THAT WILL
ACTUALLY BE AN APPENDIX TO THE
PATHWAYS REPORT. SO WE'RE GONNA
HAVE A- NOT EVERY PROGRAM BUT
SORT OF THE TOP FIVE PROGRAMS
THAT ARE REALLY GOING TO MAKE A
PUT OUT OF WE DID A SURVEY AND
THAT SURVEY WE ASKED YOU KNOW
HOW MANY ACRES DO YOU THINK YOU
CAN GET. WITH THIS PROGRAM THIS
YEAR AND IN COMING YEARS YOU
KNOW UNDER AT LEAST THIS BY THE
- INITIATIVE. AND SORT THROUGH
THAT EFFORT I DID A VERY GROSS
DON'T ASK ME FOR THE DETAILS
BACK OF THE ENVELOPE
CALCULATION. AND I THINK WE'RE
REALLY ON THE PATH AS LONG AS WE
CONTINUE THIS PARTNERSHIP AND WE
DRIVE ON THESE VERY. DIFFERENT
APPROACHES SO IT'S NOT ALL JUST.
ACQUIRING LAND THROUGH THE NOTES
STATE COPPERS BUT THERE'S A DESK
. OF WAYS TO GET THERE I THINK
IT IS AMBITIOUS BUT ALSO VERY
DOABLE. AND THEN ONCE REQUIRE
ALL THIS LAND I THIS TO. OF THIS
LAND AND I WANNA AT. JOIN THE
CHORUS OF MY COLLEAGUES WHO ARE
COMMENDING YOU FOR YOUR
PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR NATIVE
PEOPLE BECAUSE I THINK THEY'VE
BEEN. INCREDIBLE STORIES OF OUR
LAND WELL WE HAVE GOT HERE- BUT
AS WE ACQUIRE THIS LAND
OBVIOUSLY THE ON GOING
STEWARDSHIP OF THIS LAND IS
REALLY CRITICAL WORK WE HAVE.
BEEN OUR WILDFIRE PROBLEM IS IN
PART BECAUSE WE HAVE NOT BEEN
MAINTAINING OUR LANDS AS WE
SHOULD HAVE. SO I GUESS PART OF
MY QUESTION IS OKAY WE HAVE THIS
GREAT GOAL WE'RE GOING TO GET
THEIR WHAT IS OUR PLAN TO THEN.
BE PROPER STEWARDS OF ALL OF
THIS LANDS. IN PERPETUITY. I CAN
TELL YOU THAT THIS WAS A VERY
HOT TOPIC IN OUR PUBLIC
ENGAGEMENT. BECAUSE WE HAVE A
GREAT TRACK RECORD OF. GETTING
LAND UNDER CONSERVATION AND THEN
NOT ALWAYS PARK. TAKING CARE OF
IT THE WAY WE SHOULD AND NOT
INVESTING IN THAT STEWARDSHIP
AND SO I WHOLEHEARTEDLY AGREE
THAT THAT'S AN ESSENTIAL
ELEMENT- YOU KNOW. WE WERE JUST
TALKING ABOUT PRIVATE LAND
EASEMENTS YOU KNOW. WHAT'S GREAT
ABOUT THOSE IS THAT. THE
MANAGEMENT IS ACTUALLY BUILT
INTO THE WAY THAT THE LAND IS
CONSERVED AND SO THOSE ARE GREAT
EXAMPLES OF WHERE IT'S WORKING
WELL I THINK- WE NEED TO UP OUR
GAME FIRST EVER CHECK ON A LOT
OF OUR- ARE ALREADY CONSERVE
PLANS AND BUILD THAT INTO THE
PROCESS. I DON'T HAVE AN EASY
ANSWER FOR YOU BUT I. CAN TELL
YOU THAT THAT'S AN ESSENTIAL
PIECE. I AGREE THANK YOU LET'S
KEEP OUR EYE ON THAT BECAUSE
LASSEN ON DO IS CREATE A- BIG
MESSING CALIFORNIA. ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT REALLY STRUCK ME IN
IN READING YOU KNOW THE
MATERIALS AROUND THIRTY BY
THIRTY WAS HOW POORLY WE'RE
DOING ON WETLANDS THAT WE LOST
90% OF OUR WETLANDS DUE TO A
WHOLE HOST OF REASONS- AND SO IT
SEEMS LIKE. YOU KNOW I DON'T
LIVE IN AN AREA WITH MUCH- BUT-
IT SEEMS LIKE THAT NEEDS TO BE A
PRIORITY IN THIS- IS REALLY
WHERE HAVE WE TAKEN THE BIGGEST
HIT I THINK THIS GOES A LITTLE
BIT TO WHAT. MR BIGELOW WAS
FOCUSING ON AND WHERE HAVE WE
REACHED OUR GOALS WERE HAVEN'T
WE AND I THINK ONE OF THE
QUESTION SHOULD BE WHERE WE
STRUGGLING THE MOST. IN TERMS OF
BY. AND I WOULD THINK FROM THE
READ MY READING THAT THAT WOULD
BE WETLANDS IS THERE PRIOR. IN
THAT REGARD. CLINTON I THINK ANY
. IS NOT PRIORITIZING LENS IS
NOT TELLING YOU. THE WHOLE STORY
I MEAN WE KNOW THAT THAT'S
IMPORTANT WHEREVER WE ARE SOME
YES LIKE THAT. THAT'S A CRITICAL
THING IN EVERY ECOSYSTEM IS
MAKING SURE THAT THE WETLANDS OR
THE FRESH WATER THAT'S
ASSOCIATED WITH THEM OR THE
BRACKISH WATER. IS PROTECTED- SO
IN THE IN THE DOCUMENT WE
IDENTIFY- SORT OF. OUR
PRINCIPLES FOR MEETING OUR ABOUT
. CITY OBJECTIVE AND- FOR OUR
PRIORITIES I SHOULD SAY. AND IN
THAT WE IDENTIFIED UNDER
REPRESENTED ECOSYSTEMS AS KEY.
AND IT OR PLACES THAT ARE
ALREADY VERY RARE OR DEGRADED
AND YOU KNOW WHAT LET'S FALLS
INTO THAT CATEGORY THERE'S A
SUITE OF OTHER. SYSTEMS AND BLUE
OAK WOODLANDS COMES TO MIND THAT
ARE ACTUALLY REALLY DOWN TO A
VERY. SMALL PROPORTION OF WHAT
WE HAD IN THE PAST- WE- WANT TO
DO A DEEPER. DIVE INTO ANALYZING
WHERE WE HAVE PROTECTED AREAS
USING THAT CA NATURE GIS THAT I
MENTIONED. TO REALLY LOOK AT
WHERE DO WE HAVE NEEDS ACROSS
THE ECOSYSTEMS OF CALIFORNIA AND
WHERE CAN WE INVEST IN TO. MAKE
SURE WE'RE MEETING OUR
BIODIVERSITY GOALS. SO THAT'S-
WORK TO CALM AND CONVERSATIONS
THAT WE'RE HAVING. I MENTIONED
THE CALIFORNIA BIODIVERSITY
NETWORK THEY ACTUALLY HAVE A
ROUND TABLE THAT'S- DESIGNER.
THAT CONVERSATION NO WHERE IS
THE MOST IMPORTANT- PATTERSON
PROTECTIONS THAT WE SHOULD.
REALLY BE DIGGING INTO. THANK I
WOULD ALSO. I WOULD ALSO ADD ON
THE COASTAL. SIDE IT'S BEEN A-
VERY. BIG PRIORITY IN THE OCEAN
. CARE STRATEGIC PLANS BAND-
WHAT WHEN A CAR. ON YOU SEE
INVEST. THAT DR NO PUT OUT THERE
BY HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS. ON
CLOSER AS- NATURE. SOLUTIONS A
LOT OF THAT IS BECAUSE THE
WETLAND. ON AND LIVING SHORELINE
HABITAT BOTH OF WHICH ARE. ON
THERE'S SOME PRETTY SIGNIFICANT
NEEDS THEY ARE DOING HABITAT AND
IT'S REALLY. WIPED OUT ALMOST
BADLY AS- CONSEQUENCE IN THE
STATE. I'M SO THE PRIORITIES
THERE. THERE'S SOME FIND BEING
AND I CAN TELL YOU BEST OR READ
FOR. ALSO INTO ACCOUNT THE LIKE
SEQUESTERING. AND RIGHTS- ALSO
IT IS A VERY BIG PART THIS AS
WELL NOT ABOUT HER SEASIDE.
THANK YOU IN. I'M NOT GONNA DR
WILL HAVE YOU EVER QUESTIONS ON
. SO- YOU MENTIONED THAT DOING
OUR OF MARIE PROTECTED. AND SO
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BE INCLUDED
IN THE PLAN WE WENT THROUGH A
LOT OF BACK AND FORTH ABOUT.
FEDERER'S REJECT AREAS I REALLY
APPRECIATED WHAT YOU WERE SAYING
ABOUT ONLY. FOCUSING ON THOSE
AREAS THAT ARE TRULY PROTECTING
THE BIODIVERSITY OF OUR OCEANS
BUT THEN YOU ALSO AID THAT
BECAUSE OF THAT REVIEW WE'RE
NOT. GOING TO INCLUDE IN THIS
INITIAL PLAN ADDITIONAL MARINE
PROTECTED AREAS. I'M JUST
CALLING ON IT UNDERNEATH AND
YOU. THAT UNFORTUNATELY THAT'S
IT'S BEEN DARN JARGON HIM SO I
PLEDGE I FOR ALL THAT. I'M THE
ON THE- SIDE WE TALK ABOUT
NATIONALLY SANCTION. RIGHT AND
THEN ON THIS. SIDE WE MARIE PER
. AREA WERE SAYING THAT THE
STATE MARIE PROTECTED AREAS ALL
COUNT. SO THE ALL HUNDRED TWENTY
FOUR ABOUT I UNDERSTAND I'M NOT
SAYING WHAT COUNTS ANYTHING TO
GET HER GOAL WHICH WE ARE
FURTHER ON IN OCEANS WE MORE
WORK TO DO IN OUR OCEANS RIGHT.
YOU SAID BECAUSE IT A REVIEW I
THINK BECAUSE OUR ON GOING
REVIEW OF OUR MARINE PROTECTED
AREAS IN THE INITIAL PLAN THAT
WILL COME OUT IN THE COMING
MONTHS I BELIEVE. YOU WILL NOT
BE DDING ADDITIONAL MORNING
PROTECTED AREAS ALL. EXPLAINED
HOW HE EVER GET TO COSTA WATER
PROTECTION WITHOUT THAT. THREE
THREE. THAT'S THAT'S A GOOD
POINT AND HERE'S WHY. ON WHICH
IS. A LOT OF THIS IS A RESPECT
PROCESS ON ISSUE WHICH IS ABOUT
FOUR THIRTY BY THIRTY CAME OUT-
OBVIOUSLY WE'VE HAD THE MARINE
LIFE PROTECTION ACT. AND THE
NETWORK OF MPAS WAS CREATED AND
MANAGED BY TWENTY TWELVE- I'M
ONE OF THE COMMITMENTS WAS TO
PUT TOGETHER AND THE CABLE
MANAGEMENT RUBIO. I'M AT THAT
TIME. I'M THERE'S BEEN A GREAT
DEAL OF FINDING INVESTED INTO
DOING ON SCIENCE TO ASSESS. WHAT
THE APPETITE SEE AN IMPACTS OF
THAT NETWORK IT HAS SPENT A LOT
OF THE SCIENCES- HAS JUST BEEN
PUBLISHED IN THE LAST. LAST
MONTH IF YOU WANT TO TAKE A LOOK
AT IT- SO IT'S OUT THERE- SO
THIS FINAL REPORT. ASSESSING I'M
THE EFFICACY OF ON. THE EMPTY
AND OUR OVER THE DECADE WILL
COME OUT AT THE- FIRST QUARTER
OF NEXT YEAR TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. AND SO MIGHT WAS JUST.
BECAUSE THERE WERE SO MANY
STAKEHOLDERS ON ALL SIDES BUT
THEIR CONSERVATION OR IN AS WELL
AS THE FISHING ARENA AND BELIEVE
ME. SPORTFISHING A LOT DIFFERENT
THAN COMMERCIAL FISHING ON
INTEREST THERE. ON WE SAID IF
I'M THIRTY BY FOR AS WE WEREN'T
GOING TO JUMP AHEAD TO MAKE A
DETERMINATION ON WHAT WE NEED TO
DO. ON BY EXPANDING THE MPA
NETWORK INTEL ALL THE SCIENCE
AND THE ASSESSMENT IS AND SO IT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT WE'RE NOT
GOING TO DO IT AS A MATTER OF
FACT IT'S ONLY A YEAR AWAY. FROM
THE STANDPOINT OF WHAT WE CAN
START HAVING THOSE DISCUSSIONS
BUT WE MADE A PROMISE TO THE
STAKEHOLDER COMMUNITY THAT WE
WERE GOING TO POLITICIZE. ON A
DETAIL MAN REVIEW IN THAT MANNER
AND SO THAT'S THAT'S WHY WE MADE
THAT WE THOUGHT IT WAS THE
PRUDENT DECISION AT THIS TIME.
IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT IT CAN'T
AND WON'T COME UP SUBSEQUENT TO
THE COMPLETION. THAT TICKET A
MANAGEMENT REVIEW. GOT IT WELL I
WAS I THINK BASED ON OUR CALL.
TODAY IT'S PROBABLY THE MOST
EFFECTIVE WAY TO GET TO
PROTECTING THOSE COASTAL WATERS
IS ADDITIONAL ON PS I HOPE
IT'LL- BE ON THE TABLE SOON
CRIPPLE OUT OF WORK TO DO THERE.
OBVIOUSLY AND ON THAT. I'M SURE
YOU'VE HEARD FROM OUR FISHING
COMMUNITIES ON THE S. AS WE LOOK
TO EXPAND PROTECTIONS OFF THE
COAST- THE IMPACT THIS WILL HAVE
ON. THEM IN THE FOOD RESOURCE
THEY PROVIDE WHAT IS THE MESSAGE
TO OUR FISHERIES ON WHAT THE
FUTURE LOOKS LIKE. ON THE
MESSAGE TO THEM IS THAT WE NEED
TO WORK WITH YOU TO FINISH.
FINISH THE JOB ON HOW WE GET THE
THIRTY BY THIRTY ON AND SO
THAT'S WHY YOU KNOW THERE. SUCH
CRITICAL STATE. IN THIS ENTIRE
THING. ON AND JOHN AND SO THERE
WILL BE EVEN MORE DISCUSSIONS
THAT HAVE ALREADY OCCURRED. ARE
BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT GOING ON
THAT THAT'S CONCERNING IN THE
FISHERIES. SORT THINK ABOUT IT
RIGHT NOW. GET THE CABLE
MANAGEMENT RUBIO. YOU'VE GOT-
CONCERNS NOT JUST FIVE PASSED ME
IN REGARDS TO. THAT G. MMASHARE
NATIONAL SANCTUARY WITH THE
VISION. EXPRESSED CONCERNS THEY
ARE. ON THERE'S CONCERNS. I'M ON
MOVING FORWARD ON FLOATING
OFFSHORE WIND. FARM IN IN THE TO
POTENTIALLY SELL AREAS. I ANTON
AND THEN NEW REQUIREMENTS ON
EMISSIONS FROM VESSELS. THAT
HAVE BEEN BROUGHT UP QUITE A
BIT. SO THE FISHING COMMUNITIES
FEELING A LITTLE BIT PICKED UPON
BY NOW IT THIS POINT. AND SO
THAT'S WHY. MORE THAN EVER FOR
THIS PROCESS THIS IS CRITICAL
THAT WE NEED TO WORK WITH THEM
TO STAKEHOLDERS. AND YOU KNOW
GET SOME AGREEMENT ON ON HOW TO
MOVE FORWARD AND REACHED A
THIRTY BY THIRTY TARGETS. PUTS
ARMS THAT'S WHERE WE'RE AT. OKAY
THANK YOU FOR THAT. I WENT HERE
TO BE THE FINAL VERSION OF THE
STRATEGY RELEASED I THINK YOU
BOTH SAID IT WAS WORTH COMING
BUT. I DON'T KNOW THAT I. YEAH I
DIDN'T QUITE SAY SO AS- COMMON
THE COMING VERY CLOSE FEDERAL
FIFTEENTH AND WE- ASK FOR. FROM
OUR PART BY FOR. TWO EIGHTH SO.
IT'S ONLY BEEN A FEW WEEKS BUT
WE WE'VE- GOTTEN OURSELVES
LETTERS AND WE'VE BEEN COMING
THEM SO WORK. WORKING ON
FINALIZING THAT DRAFT AND
GETTING IT GETTING IT DONE
SOMEWHERE SAY SPRING. AND I'M
HOPING WITHIN A YOU KNOW A MONTH
OR SO IT'LL BE DONE. OKAY THANK
YOU I KNOW THAT I'M AS I
MENTIONED IN MY OPENING REMARKS
YOU KNOW I THINK THIS WILL BE
THE FIRST HEARING WE HAVE IN
THIS IS THIS PROCEEDS I HOPE
THE- ENGAGE WITH ALL OF YOU. I
HAVE AND MY LAST QUESTION IS YOU
KNOW HOW DO YOU SEE AS BEING
MOST AND BEST SUPPORTERS OF THIS
EFFORT I THINK EVERYBODY HERE- I
WAS REFERRED ONE BUT I THINK A
LOT OF. REALLY WANT TO SEE THIS
HAPPEN AND WANT TO MAKE SURE WE
ARE PARTNERING YOU HEARD FROM
CALL. TODAY YOU KNOW WHO FEEL
FRUSTRATION THAT THEIR
COMMUNITIES ARE NOT INCLUDED IN
SO HOW DO WE CONTINUE TO BE A
PART OF THIS CONVERSATION TO
MAKE SURE. THAT ALL THE
CONSTITUENCIES ACROSS THE STATE
ARE BEING HEARD AND INCLUDED IN
THIS. WELL I THINK HAVING
HEARINGS THIS A REAL. HELPFUL TO
HAVE THIS COME. IS A WEEK. AIR
BASED. AND WE CAN HEAR WHAT'S
WHAT'S GOING ON IN YOUR
DISTRICTS. WE ARE TRYING HARD TO
MEET AND MEET WITH. PEOPLE ALL
OVER THE STATE BUT YOU HAVE THAT
CONNECTION AND SO. ANYTIME THAT
WE CAN GET TOGETHER IN DIALOGUE
I THINK IS REALLY REALLY
VALUABLE AND I JUST. ALSO WANT
OF. EXPRESS YOU KNOW OUR
APPRECIATION OVERALL FOR THE
BUDGET ACT LAST YEAR THAT REALLY
HELPED US JUMPSTART THE
STRATEGY- THAT WAS REALLY.
TREMENDOUS AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO MORE WORK LIKE THIS IN THE
FUTURE. AWESOME WELL THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND YOUR
ENGAGEMENT IN ANSWERING ALL OF
OUR QUESTIONS EVEN WHEN WE- HAVE
HAD ASKED. BECAUSE OF OUR
CONFUSION SAID. ISN'T IT IT'S
CONFUSING. THING SO I'M GLAD
YOU'RE ALL THE- AS AS MANY LIKE
YEAH WELL AND WITH THAT I THINK
I SEE MR GOING HAVE. BEEN I JUST
HAD. A COUPLE OF THEIR- FIND.
ONCE STATE LANDS OF BY BE YOUR
BEST RESOURCE TO GET A LOT. OF
THE INFORMATION ON ALL THOSE
CONTRACTS THAT ARE OUT THERE.
AND THERE ARE TWO KINDS ARE THE
TEN YEAR. THEY RENEW EVERY TEN
YEARS THERE'S THE SECOND KIND
TWENTY FIVE. SO EACH HAS A
PERIOD OF TIME. TO WHICH YOU CAN
APPLY FOR NON RENEWAL AND
THERE'S A BUYOUT CLAUSE IN THOSE
THEY DO GO ON FOREVER AUTOMATIC.
IF YOU DON'T DO ANYTHING TO JUST
FOR CLARIFICATION. I THINK THE
REAL POINT. COMING BACK TO THE
TRIBAL ISSUE. HELP TO UNDERSTAND
THE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
WHERE DOES THAT MONEY. GO DOES
IT GO. TO THE BUREAU OF INDIAN
AFFAIRS AT THE B. I. A. AT IN
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. FOR
BECAUSE OF ALL THEIR LANDS OR
NATIONAL TRUST. SO EVERYTHING
HAS TO BE APPROVED. THROUGH THE-
THE SECRETARY OF THE INTERIOR
THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT. THROUGH
THEIR DEPARTMENT THERE- IN
CONCERT WITH THE TRIBAL
AGENCIES. BECAUSE NOT ALL THEIR
LANDS ARE TREATED THE SAME. SO
THERE'S A LOT OF MOVING PARTS.
THERE THAT ARE VERY. TECHNICAL
SO HOW DOES THAT HOW DOES WORK
FOR THE TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS. SO
THE WAY WE THE DETAILS OF THIS
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS OUTSIDER
ARE DEFINITELY STILL BEING
WORKED OUT BUT THE VISION IS
BROADLY FOR IT TO BE- A-
PROGRAMS. THE CALIFORNIA
RESOURCES AGENCY TO WORK WITH
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
TRIBES ON CONSERVATION EFFORTS
AND CLIMATE EFFORTS THAT THEY
UNDERTAKE SO- OKAY. HELLO SO
THAT NEXT PART IS WHERE IT THE
MONEY PART. CALIFORNIA'S GIVING
A GRANT ONE WE TO RECOGNIZE
THEIR THEIR A SOVEREIGN NATION
BUT THERE INTRUST THROUGH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. SEQUIN
DOESN'T APPLY ON THAT NATIVE
LANDS BUT ME BUT DOES UNDER WHAT
TERMS AND CONDITIONS WILL BE
OPERATED AND ENFORCED WHEN THOSE
GRANTS ARE GIVEN TO HIM FOR DEEP
FOR DOING SOME OF THESE PROJECTS
THAT YOU'RE REFERRING TO. WHICH
ARE RESTORATION TYPE. THOSE ARE
GREAT QUESTIONS AND WE HAVE NOT
WORKED OUT THOSE DETAILS YET BUT
I'M SURE WE CAN COME BACK AND
TALK ABOUT IT. ABSOLUTELY IT'S
GONNA BE CRITICAL BECAUSE IF
THAT BECOMES THE CASE WERE
USUALLY CALIFORNIA WANTS ONLY.
ALLOWED TO BE GRANTED UNDER THIS
EQUIPMENT. PROVISIONS THEN THEY
WON'T BE ABLE TO RECEIVE THAT
MONEY AND HAVE IT UTILIZED SO
THAT BECOMES. THE TECHNICAL KNOW
HOW DO WE HAVE THE GOVERNMENT
THE MONEY AND THEN HOW TO COME
BACK IN A IN A PROPER WAY. IT'S
A LOT OF NUANCES BUT YOU'RE
RIGHT. LIKE YOU SAY A LOT OF
TECHNICAL STUFF IS GOING ON HERE
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US TO
UNDER. I'M A HUNTER. HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OR MORE.
AREN'T BIG DOLLARS. AND WE NEED
TO KNOW WHERE IT'S GOING AND HOW
IT'S GOING TO BE USED. WELL
THAT'S WHY I'M SO GRATEFUL FOR
ALL THE ENGAGEMENT OF OUR
COLLEAGUES TO ACT THAT'S OUR
WORK WE HAVE BEFORE US AND THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR BEING AVAILABLE IN
ANSWERING ALL OUR QUESTIONS AND-
YES THERE'S MORE WORK TO BE DONE
TO MORE DETAILS TO BE HAMMERED
OUT WE'RE GONNA CONTINUETHE
CONVERSATION. SAYS THANK YOU TO
EVERYONE- DOCTOR NURSE AND
DOCTOR GOLD. WE ARE GOING TO
OPEN IT UP FOR PUBLIC COMMENT AT
THIS TIME- OPERATOR CAN YOU TELL
ME HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE ON THE
PHONE LINES. YES ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. THEREFORE PROTECT. ON
THE PHONE LINE AND WE HAVE. TO
PROTECT THE PAINT IN QUEUE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS GREAT
THANK YOU FIRST I DON'T SEE
ANYONE HERE IN THE ROOM WHEN I
OPEN IT UP FOR SOMEONE IN THE
ROOM TO PROVIDE COMMENT OKAY SO
WE WILL GO TO THE PHONE FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT WE CAN DO. AT TWO
MINUTES EACH AT OPERATOR WE OPEN
THE LINE FOR THE FIRST CONTACT.
YES IN A PARKED CAR COME FROM
LINE NUMBER EIGHTEEN. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING THANK YOU
MY NAME IS JIM DELFINO AND I'M
REPRESENTING DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE AND THE CALIFORNIA NEED
A PLAN SOCIETY AND- REALLY
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT THE
COMMITTEE- HAD A HEARING ON THIS
VERY IMPORTANT INITIATIVE THAT
CALIFORNIA IS HEADING AND
LEADING A NATION AND AS WITH
NOTE- I'LL JUST WANT TO THANK
YOU- OF FOR ALL OF THE WORK THAT
THEY HAVE PUT INTO THIS ALL OF
THE OUTREACH- THAT THEY HAVE
COMMITTED TO IT AND- ALL THE
WORK THAT IS NOW AHEAD OF THEM-
I WON TO. EXPOSE SOME THEMES
WERE RAISED BY THE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S TODAY- FIRST I
THINK IT'S- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA NOTED THE LEGISLATURE DOES
HAVE AN IMPORTANT ROLE TO ENSURE
THAT THIRTY BY THIRTY A
CONTINUOUS PATH WITH THE
MINISTRATION AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE
. TO MAKE SURE THAT- THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT INITIATIVE AND TRY AND
IS- APPROPRIATE LET WE- FUNDED-
SO THAT'S THE FIRST TO COMMENT
THE SECOND I JUST WANT TO NOTE
THAT WE ARE VERY THANKFUL OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S COMMITMENT OF
FUNDING TO TRIED- RECOGNIZING
THAT THERE ARE IMPORTANT EACH
HELPED ME WORK OUT BUT WE ALSO
NOTETHAT THERE IS- WE WOULD
ALSO ASK THAT THERE BE.
INVESTMENTS MADE INTO CAPACITY
BUILDING FOR OTHER PARTNERSHIPS-
I THINK IT'S THAT SOMETHING
GARCIA NOTED THERE'S A REAL
OPPORTUNITY HERE ARE
PARTICULARLY BY- PROVIDING
FUNDING TO COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND SMALL TRUST TO
IDENTIFY AREAS THAT ARE IN HERE-
UNDER REPRESENTED IN TERMS OF
POP PUBLIC OPEN SPACES- URBAN
AREAS AND ALSO AGRICULTURE
AREAS. LIKE IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY FRESNO THEY DON'T REALLY
HAVE- A LOT OF PUBLIC SPACE
AROUND THEM JUST SOUTH OF HERE
IN STOCK IN THE CALAVERAS RIVER
RUNS THROUGH A VERY POOR
NEIGHBORHOOD- AND IT- COULD BE
RESTORED AND PROTECTED AND
PROVIDING IMPORTANT URBAN AREA.
BUT TO IN ORDER TO GET THAT WORK
DONE I THINK SOMEBODY COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS NEED
SUPPORTING IT AFTER FOR THAT TO
BE IN THE BUDGET OR THE
LEGISLATURE TO PROVIDE FOR THAT. WE GOT THE THAT'S STRONG
SCIENCE- THAT. MAPPING FOR THE
STATE CALIFORNIA HAS NOT BEEN
COMPLETED. THAT IS A VERY BASIC
INFORMATION. AND DATA SAID THAT
WE NEED TO HAVE THE ENTIRE STATE
WE'VE MAPPED- 60% OF OUR- WE
HAVE. PERCENT LESS. I WOULD NOTE
A LOT OF IT IS AND- CO AND ALLOW
THE HEARING ABOUT AREA THAT
THAT'S- NEED TO BE- AND THEN
FINALLY I THINK THAT THE- WITH
MADE BY NOW. AND OF NUMBER BUT
WE NEED A CONVENE AND I. AND
INTO THE INTO ACT WHICH ASK WITH
. NUMBER THREE AND ONGOING
DAMAGE OF THE PLAN. THIS IS
REALLY IMPORTANT. THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL- AND THE BUDGET DEAL
FROM LAST YEAR DOES PROVIDE
IMPORTANT. INVESTMENT BUT WE
WOULD ASK THAT THOSE GET UPSIZED
- IN IN FACT THE- NUMBER OF
ORGANIZATIONS- HAD ASKED FOR AT
LEAST A BILLION ON GOING FUNDING
- TO COME. THIRTY BY THIRTY SO
THANK AFTER OPPORTUNITY FOR
THESE COMMENTS. THANK YOU
OPERATOR THAN COMMENT PLEASE. IT
WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER STEP.
PRESIDENT OF THE CAN. GO AHEAD.
I THINK YOU'RE MY CAT WE HEARD
YOU FOR A SECOND WHEN WE COUNTY
AREA. WE'RE OFFLINE. SIXTEEN
FOLLOWING CHEN MEMBERS MAKING
CLEVELAND ET'S ME AT NATURE
CONSERVANCY JUST WANT TO MENTION
THAT CALIFORNIA NEEDS
SIGNIFICANT FUNDING TO IMPLEMENT
THIRTY BY THIRTY STRATEGY WHICH
INVOLVES CONSERVING SIX MILLION
MORE ACRES IN THE NEXT EIGHT
YEARS WE WANTED URGE THE STATE
TO INVEST ONE BILLION DOLLARS TO
MEET THE NEEDS AND PRINT
BIODIVERSITY AND CREATING WHILE
BY CROSSING. TO PREVENT A HEART
ATTACK AND MITIGATION THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU. OPERATE THE
NEXT COMMENT. PATTERSON LINE
NUMBER FIFTEEN. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR TAYLOR ROCHE WITH
THE CAL FARM BUREAU THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR HER THIS FOR HEARING
INTO NORTH FOR HER PRESENTATION-
WE SUBMITTED SUBSTANTIVE TO THE
AGENCY BUT WE'D LIKE TO
REITERATE- ARE CONCERNED
REGARDING THE LIMITED TOOLS
AVAILABLE TO WORKING LANDHOLDERS
FOR BIODIVERSITY PROMOTION THREE
THIRTY BY THIRTY. SOME OF THE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S NOTED TODAY
BOTH TRADITIONAL AND BURGEONING
AG BASED PROGRAMS THAT ADVANCE
BIODIVERSITY ARE NOT PROPOSED TO
BE CONSIDERED- SO THIS INCLUDES
BUT ISN'T LIMITED TO ADD
EASEMENT EVEN THOUGH OFFERED-
UNDER PROGRAMS THAT ISSUE THAT
APARTMENT CONSERVATION U. S.
NRCS ACRES UNDER WILLIAMSON ACT
INTO BURLINGTON ACT THE
POLLINATOR HABITAT PROGRAM THAT
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER REFERENCED
AND PRESCRIBED GRAZING LEASES
WHILE BIODIVERSITY MAY NOT BE
THE PRIMACY OF THESE AGREEMENTS
BY DIVERSITY IS MOST CERTAINLY
ADVANCED AND SO THESE PROJECTS
KEEP FUEL LOADS LOW MANAGE
NOXIOUS NOXIOUS. DECEMBER AND
EXPAND IMPORTANT HABITAT FOR
THREATENED ENDANGERED SPECIES
THEY'RE ALSO THE TOL FOR THE
STATE UTILIZES TO ACTIVELY
MANAGE ITS OWN LANDS THAT IT
OWNS OR ACQUIRES- THERE'S ALSO
FEDERAL AND PRIVATE PROGRAMS
LIKE FISH FRIENDLY FARMING INTO
RIGHT FIELD HEADROOM HABITAT FOR
POLLINATORS FORAGE FOR SPECIES
LIKE TRICOLORED BLACKBIRD IN OUR
DAIRIES TO ENCOURAGE THE TO BE
CONSIDERED ALL OF THESE GO
BEYOND LAND PROTECTION INCLUDE
THIRD PARTY OVERSIGHT OF ACTIVE
MANAGEMENT. OR MULTI YEAR ACTION
EVEN SOME AND- EVEN ACT PRESERVE
THAT HOST LANE SENATE CONTRACT
WITHIN THE CONTEXT OF DURABILITY
GO THROUGH A FORMAL RULE MAKING
PROCESS FOR LOCAL THEM GENERAL
PLAN. A STATE STATUTE AN
EXTREMELY EXPENSIVE AND LABOR
INTENSIVE ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCEDURE FOR CONTRACT
CANCELLATION SO WE MOST
CERTAINLY BELIEVE THAT BEST
MEETS THE METRIC OF DURABILITY-
AND WHILE WE APPRECIATE WE MAY
BE PART OF THE BROADER NATURE
BASED SOLUTION NOT BEING
INCLUDED IN THE PATHWAYS WERE
CONCERNED CREATES A PERCEPTION
THAT HE AG COMMUNITY DOESN'T
AND CAMPS- COMPLIMENT
BIODIVERSITY SO WE ENCOURAGE.
AND HARMONIZATION BETWEEN STATE
FEDERAL AND LOCAL EFFORTS AND
ANY OPPORTUNITY THAT WE CAN TAKE. WE HOPE AND MATH STE THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU. OPERATOR THE
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS. YES LINE.
WARNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS
IS JOE APPEARING IN ON OF MY
CLIENT UP AND ARGUMENTS CENTER
AND COMMUNITY ON BUT THE FARMERS
WE WERE JUST BY DOES OF ORG.
THAT THE FIRST ARRAY ON FISH AND
WILDLIFE CONSERVATION
ORGANIZATIONS RCDE TRIED- IN
OTHER CONSERVATION AND IN
COMMENTS THAT WE SUBMIT TO THE
AGENCY WHO WE SHARE- APPLY ON
THE SUPPORT FOR THE EFFORT THAT
THEY'RE MAKING AND DEVELOPING
THE FINAL PLAN FINAL STRIDE. BUT
OUR COMMENTS WERE FOR ON A
STRONG THE FOR THE INCLUSION OF
BEAVER AND PROJECT BASED
RESTORATION STRATEGY TO HELP
ACCOMPLISH THE STATE THIRTY BY
GOAL BEAVER AND CROSS THE FACE
ARE IN EVERY AND NEED BASED ON
THAT ENHANCE THE CONTENT OF
EXISTING LANDS ACCELERATE READ
LED. EXPAND ACCELERATE
ENVIRONMENTAL RESTORATION
STRENGTHENED AMONG GOVERNMENTS
AND HE PARTNERS AND A LINE
INVESTMENT TRANSACTION
CONSERVATION BENEFIT THAT THE
STRATEGY AND EVENING TO ACHIEVE
WE PROVIDE DETAILED COMMENTS
THAT WILL ALSO SHARE WITH YOUR
COMMITTEE BUT WE'RE EXCITED
ABOUT THE POSSIBILITY OF BOTH
AND EXPANDING THE RANGE OF THIS
MONTH MADE IT EASY AND VERY
CUSTOMER STRATEGIES. THAT CAN
HELP US OUR WATER OUR LAND AND
THEN OURS ARE EGO BIO DIVERSITY
OF OUR SO THANK YOU FOR THE
HEARING AND IT UP TO COME. THANK
YOU. NO COMMENTS LINE SEVENTEEN.
IT MORE CAN YOU ME NOW YES. OUR
RIGHT NOW WE'RE COOKING SIXTY
THINKING THE WRONG COUNTY WHERE
OF WERE THIRTY NINE ROCKY STATE
GOOD MORNING I. RT RC THE NEW
ROBOT COMMENT TO AN R. A. ON
THAT. DRUG DRAFT IN FELL I'M
JUST TO REENTER IF YOU OF OUR
COMMENTS FROM THAT DOT HERE A
FIRST OF ALL WE THOUGHT THE
DOCUMENT. INCOMPLETE AND WE'RE
LOOKING FORWARD TO THE NEXT
ITERATION OF THE DOCUMENT THAT
GOING TO BE COMING OUT WITH-
LEAST THE- DURING THE TO BE THE
MORE NEXT WITH HOW CALIFORNIA
VERSION THIRTY THIRTY IS GOING
TO CONNECT WITH WHAT THE FEDERAL
AS WITH THEIR AMERICAN STRATEGY
. WE KNOW THAT CALIFORNIA HAS
MORE THAN 40% FEDERALLY MANAGED
LANDS AND SO WE'RE INTERESTED
SEE HOW CALIFORNIA GOING TO WORK
TOGETHER WITH THE FANS ON AT
LEAST STRATEGY MAKING THEM MORE
KERR MONEY. WE WERE ALSO A
LITTLE BIT IN THAT AS THE- CAL
DOCKING DID NOT THE HOW
GOVERNMENTS WORKING TO BE PART
THE START AND THE- IN THEIR ADS
SECTION ABOUT WHO THEIR PARTNERS
WERE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FEEL VERY
TO. COUNTY PART LAND
PARTICULARLY SINCE WE HAVE A
PLANNING AND- WE ARE WE ARE
GIVEN A LOT OF RESPONSIBILITY
THE PLAN MANAGEMENT AND FINALLY
THERE'S BEEN A COUPLE OF
MENTIONS OF THE WILLIAMSON ACT
AND COUNTIES ARE VERY
ENTHUSIASTIC. IN AGRICULTURAL
AREAS ABOUT THE WILLIAMS ACT
HOWEVER MOST OF OUR COUNTY STILL
LIKE THE STATE IS KIND OF
ABANDONED THAT PROGRAM AND IT
HAS NOT BEEN FUNDED FOR SEVERAL
YEARS THAT'S A PROGRAM THAT
REALLY NEEDS TO BE GIVEN A GOOD
HARD LOOK AT HOW IT REALLY FITS
INTO NOT JUST THE PROGRAM BUT
THE STATE'S PLAN A LONG TERM AND
SHORT TERM FOR CONSERVATION. I
BECAUSE WE FEEL LIKE IT'S BEEN
SORT OF LEFT WITH THE COUNTY THE
KIND OF HOLDING AT FELLOW AT WE
THANK YOU FOR HAVING THIS
HEARING TODAY WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO ON THIS TOPIC.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MADAM
CHAIR WHERE LOCAL SPEAK IN Q.
RIGHT THANK YOU WELL THANK
EVERYONE FOR HEARING WE NOW I
TURNED